morning everyone welcome to the house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have a number of
committee hearings today on various
bills but before we do get to those I'd
like you to join me please in the Pledge
of Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible through liberty
and justice for all
thank you
the first bill to be considered today
and I've got to put these on
his house bill 215 and I would like to
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Mark Pearson
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the House Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee
for the record I am Mark Pearson
chairman of the children and family law
committee
my assignment as a member of the
Rockingham County delegation is our
nursing home of 226 Beds which puts me
right in the middle of what this bill is
about
the bill before you House Bill 215 would
allow the Department of Health and Human
Services to adopt rules that would
permit licensed nursing assistance also
known as lnas who take an extra course
so that they may pass medication to
participate in the tuition reimbursement
program under the State Medicaid plan
the New Hampshire Association of
counties represented behind me worked
closely with DHHS last summer to ensure
that these lnas would be appropriately
included as people who could do this
task
such a change would be helpful in at
least two ways
first it would encourage lnas to expand
their careers with another step up the
ladder
secondly it would help even if in a
small way with our Workforce shortage
long-term care facilities are facing so
that someone else could do a task that
someone much further up would no longer
have to do and be able to do the tasks
they're specifically trained for
we received information
last Thursday timing people from the
feds
that
um
the
federal government will not reimburse us
for that
um research has just been done to find
out okay if we have to pay for it what
would it be and the figure is twenty
thousand dollars that's it
and for twenty thousand dollars we are
helping
people come up the ladder and we are
also making sure that in a little way
some of the negatives of our Workforce
shortage could be mitigated so that is
my testimony on the bilser
thank you questions for representative
Pearson yes representative I was paying
attention but
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question twenty thousand dollars for the
year
or how many workers
I believe specific details are best left
to okay those folks you know me I'm the
liberal arts kid what do I know about
details and I'm the liberal arts kid
asking questions thank you they'll tell
you where and how much and all that
stuff thank you
other questions
you see know the yes representative
Lanza
hi um could I ask you
um who
in giving these medications
um what um
would they know what pills they'd be
giving and they would know the side
effects of the medications
there was a training course that they
will undergo so that they will be
brought up to the knowledge level of
people who presently administer such
meds
the questions
seeing no other questions thank you sir
also signed up to speak our attorneys
Brian Clark and John Williams from the
Department of Health and Human Services
foreign
Mr chairman and members of the Health
Human Services elderly Affairs committee
for the record I am John Williams I'm
the legislative director for the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services and with me today is I'm Brian
Clark general counsel for the Bureau of
Illinois Adult Services and keeping our
testimony in the context of a
three-minute or less testimony we do
have wonderful folks coming behind us
from the New Hampshire Association of
counties commissioner David Ross and
also miss Kate Horgan who worked really
diligently in engaging the department on
this important initiative simply put
this initiative is a an attempt to
providing funding or a reimbursement for
training of lnas to become a a medical
nursing assistant and there's currently
already existing in-state process under
the office of licensure certification
professional excuse me office of
professional licensure and certification
which almost took me to three minutes to
saying that entity's name that they are
are in fact the ones that do the
licensing under the Board of Nursing so
this this is a really a helpful attempt
in terms of Workforce capacity to
opening it up to individuals to getting
this training
um and by um and the information that I
expect that you'll likely hear from
Commissioner Ross although we're looking
to what we're currently providing in
terms of reimbursement for lnas for
similar programs so to let you know this
is not new new or novel we're doing it
for lnas to provide an offset which the
FED does provide for a federal match so
these would be general fund dollars
based upon the directive that we receive
back from our the information received
back from the centers for Medicaid and
Medicare and Medicaid services that we
can't get a match so it's a really
modest sum of an investment of twenty
thousand dollars general fund dollars
for each respective State fiscal year so
I do think this is a bill that although
we did not take a position on we are
certainly supportive of initiatives that
promote Workforce capacity and the
numbers that I think you're going to
hear from the counties are 100
individuals have been identified who
would Avail themselves of this
opportunity to having their training uh
cost reimbursed and the training costs I
understand is 200 per individual so I
apologize for stealing the Thunder of
the County Association but they'll be
here to testify on the good works that
they do and we are so certainly
supportive of the concept but there is a
need for a modest general fund
appropriation and from chairman Pearson
from the children family law committee I
understand there'll be a conversation uh
if this committee sees fit to seeing
this is an important enough Bill to pass
to having conversation with division
three even though this is not an early
bill would not go before them but to
seeing working it into the house phase
of the budget for that investment
thank you
Tony Clark did you have any additional
comment or I do not do not okay
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for um for your
testimony and helping us understand this
uh I'm wondering
um so you're saying that this training
is our there is some training that's
already going on that Medicaid is paying
for federal government is at
yeah so we are currently reimbursing a
licensed nursing assistants who complete
their licensed nursing assistant
training uh this would be a Medicaid
nursing uh medication nursing assistant
training on top of that so an additional
training that they would now have access
to
follow up
and um
so I'm just wondering
um
how this particular language is allowing
that to happen since it's it's giving
authority to the department to create
administrative rules is it can you just
clarify oh
yes of course uh So currently we have
administrative rules about our
reimbursement program and our
reimbursement program is limited to
reimbursing for the licensed nursing
assistant training so this bill would be
directing us to expand it
thank you very much
I see another hand on this side
any other questions oh yes
representative Murphy yeah thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question just to be clear
um is the additional training they're
getting for administration of
medications beyond what they get in
their traditional LNA you know
curriculum wherever they previously
trained
yes
one follow-up follow-up thank you um and
is there any
um stipulation as to which scheduled
drugs they are allowed to administer uh
at that as an l a
I'm not aware of that question but I can
find out okay thank you
other questions
yes representative McLean so then just
to clarify after representative Murphy's
question the the program already exists
the the training already exists it's
just that currently
um either they're paying out of pocket
or the counties are paying for it so
there's no change in the availability or
the the curriculum it's just
who is paying essentially that's correct
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question
um I was hoping that you could also
provide some scope over what that
training is because I appreciate the low
cost of 200 but also with administering
drugs that could have a narrow
therapeutic window I just like to better
understand exactly what training they're
doing they're getting and what they can
do with that training and chairman
McDonald and responding one of the
reasons why I stated up front that there
was an existing program it is managed by
The Entity oplc which I won't even try
again saying the entity's name so we're
really not in a position to getting into
the details of that training and again I
think that represent McLean specifically
addressed that this is about
reimbursement for those trainings that
already exist so this is not expanding
the scope of the training or changing it
at all
thank you other questions
so you know other questions thank you
gentlemen
also signed up to speak is David Ross
from Hillsborough County
sure if you'd like to sure
and also recognize Kate Horgan from the
New Hampshire Association of counties
good morning for commissioner chairman
sorry
um and committee members for the record
my name is David Ross and I am the
administrator of Hillsborough County
nursing home and Kate Horgan I represent
the New Hampshire Association of
counties which is all of your elected
and appointed officials at the county
level
I am here to request your support of
House Bill 215 for reimbursement of
licensed medication nursing assistance
as has already been presented before the
committee that licensed medication
nursing assistants are already approved
through the New Hampshire Board of
Nursing and they are functional we are
really looking to provide support to our
health care team
as part of the workforce shortage by
supporting our nurses with additional
resources to be able to help with
medication administration medication
administration is only one facet of a
licensed nurse's role in the long-term
care facility specifically we really
rely upon their skills and their
education to be able to help us with
clinical assessment overall management
of patients and symptom
presentation and communication with
their physician and their health care
team
um relieving them from responsibility of
administering routine medications
um which is takes up a support a
substantial part of their day we don't
want nurses tied to the med cart doing a
task that someone else can be
appropriately trained to do medication
assistants are able to give medications
to medically stable patients and only
certain types of medications they can't
give injections and there's and they
can't give medications that are given
with certain parameters unless the
patient is actually assessed by a nurse
so if someone needs a medication because
they're presenting with new symptoms it
requires assessment by the nurse and
approval of the nurse to be able to give
that medication so it's just those
routine medications that someone would
normally be taking much like in a home
setting where you know that someone's
taking medications at 9am 1 pm 2 p.m
routinely
any changes in that require intervention
from the nurse
given the workforce shortage we want to
be able to free up nurses to be able to
do that
I do have to make a correction to the
testimony today we didn't really quick
math this morning and we haven't had
enough coffee the the cost of the
program is two thousand dollars per
student and really we're looking for a
hundred students which would be two
hundred thousand dollars not twenty
thousand dollars so it is substantially
more than was presented earlier and I
want to make sure I'm I'm giving you
factual information but it is about an
80 hour
um clinical class that they go through
um with classroom training where they're
learning about medications and then it's
additional
um 40 hours of clinical Hands-On
observation under the direct supervision
of a nurse to make sure that they're
competent to do that
um they do receive a licensure by the
oplc as was previously testified so they
have to pass examinations so it's not
just a a pass-through process it is a
rigorous training for those individuals
and I would just Echo uh administrators
Ross comments this is something that
could really assist the counties in
terms of Workforce and making sure that
we are serving our most vulnerable
populations effectively
um we're happy to take any questions
that the committee has
yeah representative McLean thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question I appreciate very much you
clarifying you know the dollar amount
but two hundred thousand dollars is a
significantly bigger nugget than twenty
thousand so I have a two-part question
if the chair would indulge me the first
one is when the person completes this
course of training do they
um get an increase in compensation and
if they do you know about how much that
would be
yes they do and it varies by facility so
it would be inappropriate for me to
share
um really what that would be I know for
our facility um it's about a two dollar
an hour increase in their compensation
and so just on the quick follow-up with
with that incentive already in existence
um
realistically what kind of impact do you
think this would have as an additional
incentive seeing as the increased
compensation is already there the
biggest barrier to many folks pursuing
their education is the cost of the
education itself so so being able to
provide the opportunity for folks to be
able to receive that education is
helping them make that step up
um Folks at the L A level are not highly
compensated individuals oftentimes
making between 15 and 17 dollars an hour
so coming up with the additional Monies
to be able to fund education is often
the highest barrier for them to pursue
that
you're welcome representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um from the administrative uh point of
view at the nursing home do you think
that this um enhancement of their
practicing at the top of their license
will allow you in some way or another to
open more beds which is clearly a
problem in the county homes
ideally that is always Our Hope and for
us the biggest barrier to opening beds
is Workforce so anything that we can do
to be able to keep folks into the
healthcare Workforce is necessary right
now we are losing Folks at the L A level
to non-health care Fields because of
wage incentives providing a clinical
ladder an opportunity for professional
growth is an opportunity to be able to
keep folks in the field if they can make
one more step towards becoming a
licensed nurse that is a great step
forward for us thank you
other questions representative Cushman
thank you for being here and thanks for
taking my question thank you Mr chairman
um do you know if this course that they
take can be applied if they go towards
credits to earning an LNA
like I mean sorry becoming an LPN
um I do not believe that it that it um
is applied towards their education but I
do believe that it does help them with
their practice and and that knowledge
because they are learning about
medications and they are learning about
the clinical impacts of medications that
knowledge really gives them a leg up as
they're getting their nursing school
studies
other questions representative
and thank you for taking my question so
I would guess that there's a substantial
difference in Pay between
the people that would be taking this
training and a regular nurse
so it would be saving the nurse who's
paid at a much higher rate a lot of time
to okay so it probably will pay for
itself thank you thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh I'm just trying to
understand if the goal of this bill is
to deal with current crisis of
Workforce shortage
uh would it be possible to put some
amendment to limit the scope of this
expenditure just to this crisis
situation so let's say even two years
this Workforce crisis will go away this
incentive may go over as well
thank you
that's certainly a possibility I would
applaud and appreciate any opportunity
to be able to help us in the interim
um
and I guess I'll leave it at that just
to add to that representative uh we had
a Workforce shortage in crisis before
covid came in covid made it worse but it
was uh we were already in a staffing
shortage in a staffing crisis before
kovid
and and if I can dovetail on that a
little bit
um the projections for
um the needs for long-term care going
forward only increase as our population
continues to age we are facing as you've
all heard the silver tsunami that it
that is coming and the need to be able
to build our health care Workforce is
going to be with us for many years to
come at a time when we have many more
nurses that are retiring than are
graduating so we need to do everything
in our power to be able to help build a
Workforce in a way that's going to be
meaningful and sustainable
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
indulging me for a second question
um are the counties
um do you know if any of the County
nursing homes are are doing this kind of
tuition reimbursement now
many facilities throughout the counties
and throughout the state are providing
that
um there just isn't a mechanism for
reimbursement for that through for those
individual facilities so there's an
additional cost and burden on Health
Care operations we're looking for
support from that
okay just a little clear uh clarifying
question
um so you're looking so right now it's
coming from the county budget and you're
looking to get reimbursed from the state
okay thank you thank you representative
Lanza
yes uh thank you for taking my question
um so right now you're asking for a two
hundred thousand dollars
um well that also be uh for next year as
well included another 200 000 yes so
it's 2 200 000 annually yes all right
and um can I follow up with another
question
um the hundred student or the 100
nurse's aides that you'll be using is
that throughout the whole state or is
that just within uh certain counties
that would be throughout the state
throughout the state okay thank you
other questions
yes representative King
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions will this be reimbursing any
strictly private entities at all
potentially
um
um it the license the availability of
individuals to receive this program it
depends on I guess it would ultimately
depend on how the rules were written it
would come down this this bill
authorizes the development of rules so
how the rules were written would dictate
which facilities would be eligible
thank you
other questions
so you know other questions thank you
thank you thank you all
I'm not sure
in point of fact the dollar amount is a
red herring to this committee because
this committee is simply being asked for
policy change it is not an early bill it
doesn't involve money it isn't going to
division three for their approval it
just simply says may this be done may
lnas be trained to administer medicine
how many are trained to do that and at
what cost is not the scope of the bill
and therefore not really Germaine at
this point to this committee
so in other words it doesn't mandate it
it just allows for it yes sir
any questions of these gentlemen
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
coming back up
um I I believe we had heard that some
people are that L A's are already
getting this training I'm just curious
about that mechanism if this would be
enabling legislation and that's already
being provided if he could just help me
understand
and chairman McDonald a response to
represent Leon's question if you look at
the legislation itself it shows you
where we're seeking to getting or not we
but the bill and the bill sponsor um is
bringing an amendment to adding uh the
um medication uh nursing assistance to
the current rulemaking Authority that we
have around licensed nursing assistance
to getting this training so that's
already an existing law uh relative to
that mechanism for rulemaking as you
heard from attorney Brian Clark we do
have roles in place already for that uh
point of clarification we do have within
our budget under class 504 on the class
line and appropriation for four hundred
thousand dollar general fund for the
biennium so those are request currently
for the lnas and so that does mirror
somewhat what the testimony from the
county association's provided it was a
little bit of a surprise to us the
increase by an additional zero to it but
as stated by represent Pearson this is a
very important mechanism all that is
being sought here is to adding the
ability for reimbursement of those funds
so whether there's zero dollars that are
put into the budget it would at least
still allow that mechanism for
reimbursement for this important program
or a sliding scale all the way up to
potentially the two hundred thousand
dollars that is a separate conversation
with the
um with the legislature before division
three and health Finance there's nothing
this legislation that creates an
appropriation or a funding mechanism
other than the ability to do that
representative cofult
forgive me if I if this has been said
and I missed it but um
my understanding is that this would
shift
some tasks from
from licensed nurses to nurses
assistants
presumably that incurs some kind of
savings in the process has anybody done
an analysis on the cost savings that
would be offsetting some of the expenses
involved with this if it were to pass
not to my knowledge representative what
I see it is a way to help with a serious
shortage of help if an RN
is administering medications
that RN may not necessarily at that
moment be doing what the RN is trained
to do if a license nursing assistant can
do it now it will primarily in my
vantage point help with our shortage
other questions
seeing none
oh representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for indulging me
again reading this again closer and I
apologize for not doing that sooner it
says that this is for this Improvement
of the program for assistance to nurses
and I don't see that defined anywhere my
question is if having this for
assistance to nurses was actually
intended for licensed nursing assistance
in the first place and some
clarification as to what an assistant
nurse actually is would be helpful
it clearly was
um and also the cross-reference that you
can't see because it's not here to RSA
326 b14 Roman 2A that gets you to the
board of nursing statute so I'm sure if
you pull up that statute will give you
better clarification as to the scope of
who it is that is being trained here uh
to getting certified to providing
medication under that program
so it's essentially an LNA that's a
heightened LNA that's allowed to
dispense medicine
thank you that makes sense it's the
assistance to nurses and the language
that's there and it's probably would be
a matter of follow-up to understand what
an assistant to nurses is when it's not
defined and and reply on that as we can
see is in current law which is why we're
here only on the section so certainly if
your intent here is to clean the
language up further
um certainly that's the will of the
committee and if you have time to do
that certainly I know the county
associations and our agency would be a
resource to you
representative Murphy thank you for uh
once again taking my question so is it
fair to say that given that there's no
uh ask for appropriation that this is a
policy question regarding basically the
ability of everybody in the care
profession to practice up to their
license which then allows the improved
here may also lead to increasing the
ability to take care of more patients
perhaps even opening up as I mentioned
before
yes thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
gentlemen
foreign
no one else has signed up to speak on
House Bill 215 does anyone else wish to
speak
seeing no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 215 and
open the public hearing on House Bill
136 of the Prime sponsor representative
Gary Merchant was unable to be with us
this morning he's asked representative
Erica Leon to present the bill in his
place
representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman for the record I'm
representative Erica Leon from dairy
which is Rockingham 13. I am presenting
this bill on the behalf of
Representative Gary Merchant as a little
bit of background this is actually a
good fit as I do have some experience
with the home education advisory Council
which provides similar oversight
so I have the written testimony from
representative Marchant here
um and
um I I will read that in although I know
that's normally not our procedure when
I'm standing in for somebody it seems to
be appropriate
um this is representative Merchant
before serving in the New Hampshire
House of Representatives he served on
the New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy for
10 years the last two years as a
president of the board the prescription
drug monitoring program was created
during his tenure on the board when the
board was responsible for program
oversight RSA
126-a colon 95 created in
multi-disciplinary advisory Council
composed of Physicians nurse
practitioners dentists pharmacists
veterinarians law enforcement state
agencies including the attorney general
and legislators to provide advice to the
Department of Health and Human Services
Agency on program operations and to make
recommendations and provide feedback on
the use of the program
rulemaking Authority resides with the
state agency and not with the council
openness and transparency are essential
components for fully functioning
democracies and governments during
rulemaking the state agency solicits
advice from the council however during
at least one meeting the agency stated
that it does not need to follow Council
advice
this bill simply requires that when an
agency promulgates a rule that the
council votes on the final proposed rule
via a roll call and that the outcome of
the vote be presented to the Joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules when the agency presents the final
role to gel car this language was
developed in collaboration with the
department and that is representative
Merchant's testimony
okay representative Leon are you taking
questions or I can try and answer them
if there are any questions are there any
questions for representative Leon
seeing none okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak as
representative Mark Pearson
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I want to give a parallel to
what representative Merchant has
proposed he and I have discussed this he
thought it would be helpful for me to
share
during the pandemic I worked very
quietly with members of DHHS it wasn't
anything legal I didn't have a veto but
that collaborative work done very
quietly I think helped considerably
today I meet with senior members of the
Judiciary of our state on the same kind
of thing only having to do with court
procedures
in addition last fall I worked with some
of the area agencies which look after
the developmentally delayed population
with some loved ones of DD people and
with relevant people at DHHS
one of the
things I learned from this shuttle
diplomacy
is that we need more transparency we
need more communication we need more
mutuality and what I'm seeing in
representative Merchants Bill is saying
the same thing
we do need checks and balances we do
need oversight we do need collaboration
and as a result when his bill came
forward I said I'd like to talk with you
about my experiences and he said it
would only underscore what he's trying
to do thank you Mr chairman
thank you questions
any questions for representative well
perhaps you present on the bill sorry I
did thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is
um our Michael Holt and John Williams
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
good morning Mr chairman members
committee again John Williams the
director for Elizabeth affairs with me
is
my name is Michael Holt I'm a section
administrator for the division of Public
Health Services who oversees the
prescription drug monitoring program
and we we appreciate the opportunity
also for the introduction of the bill
that Revenant Leon did an amazing job in
a place of Representative Merchant uh
represent Merchant did reach out to our
agency as uh Mr Holt is the
administrator in our agency over to
prescription drug monitoring program
this involves that advisory Council that
oversees that program he worked very
diligently with us to strike the right
Accord between transparency and a um in
recognition of the fact that the
department ultimately has the rulemaking
authority around this so with that uh we
are absolutely fine this is a
demonstration of a good approach to
reaching out to State agencies to
develop legislation and we appreciate
the opportunity to appearing for you
today Mr Holt I don't know if you had
anything to add the only thing I'd like
to add is that we cannot the department
can operate under the structure proposed
I'm sorry could you repeat that please
the department can operate under the
procedure proposed by the legislation
are you taking a position on the bill or
no you're not okay thank you uh
questions
yes representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just bear with me I
think it took me up until your testimony
to understand what the bill does so I
apologize and I I just want to kind of
clarify so all that this bill is asking
them is that the agency puts forth a
rule then the advisory Council looks at
the rule and says we like it or we don't
like it they have a roll call vote and
when it goes to jailcar they're just
able to compare the two to make a more
informed decision
the the Nuance here in this bill is that
that roll call vote happens on the final
proposal of the rule as opposed to the
initial proposal or while the rules
being developed uh there's a grant of
authority in the law already that
requires the advisory Council uh to make
recommendations on rulemaking uh which
is standard practice for advisory
councils and it would be standard
practice for the Department to engage
them throughout the rulemaking process
this adds a new Step where it would
require us to bring the final proposal
before the council for a roll call vote
yay or nay and for the record uh Mr Holt
was the administrator for our
administrative rules unit which you can
tell from his answer to that question
other questions
any other questions yes representative
Cushman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so would this
mechanism be able to be used for interim
rule proposals
there is no final proposal
involved in the interim rulemaking
process or the emergency rulemaking
process and so those two forms of
rulemaking are not contemplated in this
bill
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
gentlemen thank you
no one else has signed up to speak on
House Bill 136 does anyone else wish to
speak
seeing no one else I am going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 136 and
open the public well actually
yeah we have to wait I think yeah it's
only 9 40. uh House Bill 642 is not
scheduled till 10 A.M
so we are going to be in recess for the
next 20 minutes
thank you
are there other agencies
that have similar similar mechanisms
yeah because you know that's a Judicial
Council
um
you can look
I'd like to reconvene and opened the
public hearing on House Bill 642 FN and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Stringham uh thank you
very much Mr chairman and uh thank you
uh esteem to members of the committee uh
proud and happy to be here my name is
Jerry Stringham I'm the representative
from Lincoln and Woodstock uh and um
pleased to introduce hb642 this bill
relates to prohibiting the Department of
Health and Human Services
from enforcing salary caps for direct
care workers this bill is aimed at
solving a long-standing challenge with
older budgets in the developmental
Services System
this bill doesn't title doesn't tell the
full picture of what this piece of
legislation is attempted to accomplish
so let me talk a little bit about it
first let's explore the first sentence
of the bill
the department shall not establish or
enforce in statute or rule a limit or
cap on the salary or hourly wages of
direct support staff
as recently as December of 21
dhh budget templates for developmental
Services would not allow direct support
professionals or dsps wages over
certainly our hourly rates without
bureaucratic justification while at the
same time most entry-level jobs paid the
same level or above the DHHS threshold
this obviously created some challenges
for fulfilling the services
um area agencies or non-profit private
corporations funded in large part
through and supervised by the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services Bureau of Developmental
Services area agencies provide programs
and services for people with
developmental disabilities in their
families
the area agencies are pleased that this
budget template cap is not is no longer
an issue as the practice has stopped at
least for the time being however it is
possible that these template thresholds
could return in the future in part this
bill seeks to avoid a future crisis
created when salary caps are instituted
so the focus of HB 642 is the ability
for area agencies to request a
reasonable cost of living adjustment to
an individual's budgets for budgets
older than two years old under the
current system if an individual comes
off the way waitlist and has consistent
needs in life circumstances there is no
mechanism to raise the budget
to the current labor and inflation
realities this puts both the service
providers and the individual who receive
support at risk
uh so
hb642 then is designed to work as
follows area agencies will request
request additional funds for these older
budgets if DHHS agrees that the request
is reasonable and funds are available
either through vacancies budget laps or
other sources DHHS must fund the request
if the funds are not available then the
individuals can be placed on the wait
list as alleged Legacy budget this will
provide us with data on how many Legacy
budgets will need to be addressed in the
cost to do so I noticed that the fiscal
note was updated
which indicates that there's no no added
cost for implementing this bill it's not
about adding funds to the system it's
about increasing transparency on what we
were providing and what is needed not
force payment
without appropriate additional funds
being allocated through the standard
process
so with that I I bring House Bill 642
for your consideration and I know
there's there's people here who have
more direct
interaction with the system to answer
questions but I'll be happy to try to
answer any questions that you may have
as well thank you
questions
that Senator Leon thank you Mr chairman
and thank you representative for being
here and introducing this bill
um I guess I have a two-part question my
first is if a redesign of the BDS system
would still Place Us in this same
situation and then the second part of
the question is if if these salary caps
have anything to do with Medicaid
matching funds in your knowledge
you know my my understanding would be
that um
that the Medicaid matching funds would
would is based on actual expenditures so
um you know for providing a different
number of services but still the same
dollar amount than the Medicaid the
federal matching Provisions wouldn't
change and um your your first question
um
um you know I don't think I know the
answer to that what I do know is the
system as it is now I've heard enough
direct examples when it's been an issue
that
um that it's currently an issue
so
um
and whether it wouldn't be an issue with
the change changes
um I can't I can't speak to that maybe
somebody else could
thank you
other questions
I'm saying no other questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
Melissa Nemeth from the Department of
Health and Human Services
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Melissa Nemeth
and I am the legislative liaison for the
Bureau of Developmental Services through
the Department of Health and Human
Services as as representative Stringham
pointed out there currently is not a
salary or wage cap for the payment to
direct support provider so what happens
currently is the area agency sends a
request for proposal and you know a
provider agency will reflect what their
cost is to provide the service and a
budget then comes to the Department of
Health and Human Services for approval
one of the line items in the budget is
the payment to the direct support
providers there is not a wage cap
previously there was a their requirement
for a justification if the payment to a
direct support professional is going to
be over a certain threshold but that is
no longer the case so sort of what
happens in in today's world is that it's
a a little bit of a name your own price
where the provider agencies reflect what
their cost is to provide a service
Additionally the department does not
have the data as to whether when it
approves a budget that says for example
the hourly wage for a direct support
provider is say for example 15 per hour
well the department doesn't have data
for is if all of that fifteen dollars is
passed on by the provider agency to that
direct support professional
um so we're we're not sure if that is
the case or not it's up to the employer
to pay their uh staff the wage that they
feel is appropriate
um so all of these factors are Again
part of the reason for a redesign that
the a portion of the redesign that the
department is going through with respect
to rates there has been a great deal of
information gathered as to what does it
actually cost to provide these services
and the department is working with a a
contractor to take all of this
information and develop rates going
forward and it's going to be a rate per
service
despite it being a rate per service part
of the underpinnings are
there one of the most direct costs to
provide these Services is what you have
to pay for labor so that is sort of at
the building block of what all these
rates are going to be
foreign
s are fair and Equitable across the
system for the service that is provided
so that
um we're getting away from the system
that we have now that's not a provider
specific payment but rather a service
specific payment
with that being said as as they've been
referred to as Legacy budgets or budgets
that you know are are very old
the department is going to also review
these rates that the frequency with
which they're going to be reviewed has
not yet been determined but there is
that will be an ongoing exercise so we
don't get to the place where we have you
know things are 30 years old
um
they will be looked at on an ongoing
basis and and to do that they will
gather that will gather the costs from
the providers like we've done now to
come up with the rates that are being
developed and those are they are in the
process they have not been the new rates
have not been instituted yet the goal is
that they when they are developed they
will be piloted first so that
information can be gathered and then
assessments can be made as to whether
those rates are appropriate for the
service being provided or not
the so the department uh it sort of
feels a little bit premature at this
point to do a review of these budgets
when there is uh all this work going on
the budgets are reviewed they will be
reviewed annually when someone has their
service agreement written that outlines
all the services that they are assessed
to need
um and and the budget is built it will
be based on services that support that
individuals need so it well could be
that budgets are going to change as part
of this process because we're moving to
a whole new methodology and so where the
department has that
stepwise plan in mind that's going to be
piloted it feels like doing a review now
would be a little bit premature
and it if I could wrap up I heard the
buzzer sorry currently one of the
Department's rules
hem503.13
prohibits agencies when they're making
their budget requests from including
such things as cost of living or other
wage and compensation increases so the
department has not
captured that in the appropriation
requests to the legislature nor has the
legislature accounted for that so a
potential while it's not a fiscal impact
to the in the sense that it would
require more money necessarily right now
if the request is to work within the
current appropriation
if the current appropriation is used to
address these older budgets it could be
that folks that are waiting for and have
not received services and who were
projected to receive Services as part of
that appropriation May then not be
getting those services and there may be
a wait list created
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you questions representative
McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um so
it sounds like from your testimony that
this legislation is a little bit
premature
um however I'm trying to put all the
pieces together in my mind it sounds
like it's a very complex process that I
don't really understand so it's hard for
me to make that determination would it
be possible
um for you to provide to the committee
some kind of like a process flow chart
or something so we can kind of
understand how the pieces of the puzzle
go together
um because I think for me that would be
helpful anyways because I'm I'm having a
bit of a tough time following the whole
process uh sure so to be clear are you
looking for how the budgets are
developed now and then a comparator as
to what might happen in the future
yes something like that I just wanna so
someone they put in a put in the request
you go through you you're evaluating you
set the rates what are we looking at now
what are we looking at in the future
um I think there's a lot of discussion
about that I think on some other bills
too and I think at least for me it would
be very clarifying to better understand
these two different processes so it'll
be helpful if you could do it yes I'd be
happy to do that
other questions
seeing Oh representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking the
question
um I wanted to clarify how many people
are currently on the wait list I would
have to ask I'm sorry I did not come
prepared with that information thank you
other questions
representative King thank you Mr chair
are you in favor or against this bill I
and the department is here just to
provide information thank you
other questions
see no other questions thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Alex katrupus
from csni
and I also see someone else from csni do
you both want to come up or or do you
want to do it individually
look
sure that's fine but we'll be brief uh
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee I most of my
testimony was actually uh conveyed to
you by representative Stringham I
thought did a very good job explaining
the issues
there's really two components to this
bill the first sentence of the bill is
the issue with the wage threshold that
was a
it was a major issue for the area
agencies because
as representative Stringham said they
are
competing with retail establishments
fast food restaurants other entry-level
jobs for these workers
and to have that bureaucratic
justification threshold whatever you
want to call it it's probably not fair
to call it a salary cap but it was an
impediment
to the area agencies delivering their
services and executing the budget that
the folks in this room passed and there
there was dollars there are dollars in
the budget to pay above the cap which is
why they no longer enforce that practice
so I think the first sentence of the
bill is is fairly straightforward to me
the most important part of the bill is
is the second component and I I would
not say that this bill is premature I
say that it's long overdue this issue of
the Legacy budgets has been a problem
for for many many years and really this
this bill is an attempt to give the
department another tool to manage their
budget and if they have concerns that
addressing some of these Legacy budgets
will put more people on the wait list
than they should not uh appropriate that
level of funding but couldn't we at
least give folks an opportunity I mean
I've heard stories I don't know if it's
still true but there are people who a
few years ago had the same budget that
they were awarded when they left Laconia
State School in 1991 it hasn't changed a
lot of people in developmental Services
System have consistent needs and under
the current laws and the rsas if your
needs don't change your budget remains
flat and as people with developmental
disabilities live longer lives
these budgets don't work anymore and uh
there's significant dollars available I
wish representative Weber was here
because she brought this issue up at the
oversight committee on Friday the
department has significant lapse dollars
this budget is is going to have is going
to recognize a lot of unspent dollars so
if there are dollars that are available
that can be redirected even if we took
off five or ten of these older budgets
on an annual basis it would at least
begin to solve this problem we're not
saying that this is going to create a
huge fiscal impact I don't think that
the budgets are significant in number
but there there is a legitimate problem
out there and this just gives the
department another tool to manage its
budget the discretion under this bill is
all in their control they they can
manage their dollars execute the budget
and certainly the intent of this is not
to create
is not to create a wait list but the
other side of that is if we have a
budget that was approved 10 years ago
that's paying 11 an hour for direct
support professional
uh today that but that person maybe a
very similar uh individual maybe getting
16.50 an hour
so so how do we reconcile that if
there's dollars there let's redirect
them to the need that that that's what
this bill is trying to do and if the
dollars are not there then this bill
says let's let's at least get a registry
and a list of those people so that we
know what the costs are and then the
legislature can can either fund those
needs or fund part of those needs and we
can try to move forward to solve this
issue okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you questions
so you know questions okay thank you
thank you and could we get a copy of
your testimony absolutely
thank you
also signed up to speak is Rebecca
Bryant from lrcs and csni
and again we are we have a few minutes
we're asking people to hold the
testimony for three minutes
yes thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
this morning in favor of House Bill 642
as the current CEO of Lakes Region
Community Services the designated area
agency for Region 3 and having served as
the CFO for over 10 years prior to my
current position I wholeheartedly
support this bill which is long overdue
and not premature and brings to light
one of the root causes of our inability
to retain and recruit direct care
workers just as a side note I get
updated on these numbers daily the
budgets that we're talking about are
individuals and their lives a budget
represents a life that we're serving I
currently am short 2
325 hours per week of direct support
workers in my region alone we're
currently short
748.25 hours per week in individuals who
are waiting for services to come back
after covid they're with their families
they're getting partial services but I'm
not fulfilling current isps individual
service plans short just in my day
program
748 hours a week
for many years two factors have tied our
hands and effectively capped DSP wages
one that you've heard reference to today
was the literal capping within the
budget template of the Excel cell in
which we entered the DSP wage that cell
was capped and Frozen we could not edit
that up until two years ago
a practice that has only been corrected
recently the other was the
administrative rule that you've heard
reference to the for adding individuals
to the wait list as you well know
there's two sides to a budget the
revenue side and the expense side you're
accustomed to Medicaid providers in the
area agencies advocating for a rate
increase in this situation we're asking
within the current reimbursement rate
for the ability to adjust to actual
expenses necessary to provide the
services
as you've also heard this morning in hem
50313 under the allocation of funds
section g at States and completing the
waitlist registry the area agency shall
exclude those circumstances where funds
might be needed to cover additional
expenditures such as cost of living or
other wage and compensation increases
I don't know about you but that's a
really difficult way to do business if
you've ever been in business that means
we cannot ever come forward for an
individual and say that the reason we
need a budget increase is because our
costs have increased
once an individual budget is approved by
BDS and I could happily walk you through
that process the only other way to ever
increase the budget is by placing the
individual on the wait list but we're
being told in the reg that we can't do
that by precluding the ability to place
an individual on the waitlist for wage
increases we've created 30 plus Years of
Legacy budgets and kept both families
and agencies from being competitive
employers
so it seems pretty straightforward to me
I've lived in the weeds for 17 years I'd
be happy to take questions I can
certainly I've got a lot of notes I can
answer all the questions that have Briar
been asked at least from an area agency
perspective thank you thank you
questions
anyone have any questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for coming with
all of this information
my question I'm not sure if you're the
right one to answer it around the rules
but if simply that rule around
503.13 was changed so that that was no
longer limiting would that be something
that you think would address this the
problem
in my opinion it would untie the
Department's hands from being able to
allow us to put someone on the wait list
for a wage increase currently on a
regular basis I will hear from a vendor
so some area agencies are provider
agencies we actually provide the
services some area agencies use all
contracts with vendors our vendors
currently will reach out and say and
this has happened to me with a very
large New Hampshire vendor if we don't
get these budget increases passed on
these nine individuals I'm giving notice
on them I've received that message three
times this year from that vendor then in
order to get that increase from the
bureau and put them on the wait list I
have to go back to that vendor and say I
need a justification that has nothing to
do with wages because the first email
says because we need to pay twenty
dollars an hour to get staff So
currently in my opinion as a former CFO
we're really bordering on the line of
Medicaid fraud when we say to a vendor
you need to give us a justification as
to why they're going to go on the wait
list because it can't be for wages but
we are so scared that we're going to
have them give notice on those
individuals that and you heard my
numbers on where I'm short in my region
we don't have providers in New Hampshire
and we don't have staff So currently
that is the process I hope that answers
your question it does thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
thank you
and I'm gonna try to pronounce this last
name Deborah oprimola nhcd
how did I do with the name
close enough
three minutes ma'am
please turn your microphone on
I am a member of the New Hampshire
Council of Developmental Disabilities as
a policy chairperson I'm speaking on
behalf of the council
we support HB 642 only if it's amended
we support the prohibiting of the
capping of salaries whether it comes
from DHHS or from the area agencies
both factual and anecdotal data we know
that direct providers wages are
extremely low
dhss
has put caps on the salary or hourly
wages these workers can earn McDonald's
in the state pays more than what a DSP
can earn
and it is a easier job
for this reason many families are going
without the support they need the
workforce shortage has made many
families have to make difficult
decisions the only reason I can be here
today is my husband has the flexibility
to work from home one day a week
yet in my son's budget he is entitled to
a DSP for 30 hours a week
for the past three years we have been
unable to find a worker to work at the
hourly rate cap for my son my son
deserves to be supported in the
community without his mom and dad
every adult deserves to have a life in
community that does not always include
their family
as parents and adult child I am aware
our budget hasn't changed for years
I'm also aware that the DD waiver system
is in redesign
it is not clear at this time how budgets
will be established moving forward nor
do we know the rates nor do we know how
these rates will affect
individuals who are on person directed
self-management
the question is how can the area agency
and the service provider negotiate
family service budgets without knowing
the changes and also they are not clear
in this legislation will the rates be
passed through to the families
or the DSP workers
that is unclear We Have Heard
that
there have problems
but we have not heard from the families
it's important
for the council to have questions
answered in legislation
before legislation goes through we are
here to talk about families
unfortunately at times that does include
area agencies and service providers
but today
we are concerned about the families
thank you thank you
any questions
and we could get a copy of the testimony
ma'am
thank you
also signed up to speak is Will Walker
good morning good morning thank you for
the time yeah three minutes sir my name
is Will Walker I live in Hollis New
Hampshire with my wife and a 23 year old
son with autism I'm here to ask for your
support for HB 642 what I believe it
does is help retain our most skilled and
experienced workers I believe the
current system does the exact opposite
of that it encourages our workers after
a few years to exit the system because
they are not compensated appropriately
um so I want to give a quick explanation
of the process of what it's like to find
a DSP okay so we go to the state not the
state we go to our area agency we
develop a service plan we get a budget
okay we have to then hire somebody while
our son is not receiving Services we
have to hire somebody find somebody hire
them and bring them on board and that
person had to develop a rapport with our
son that takes at least six months okay
and I would say it's six to eight months
okay during that time we have to be at
home and provide 24 7 care for our son
that limits our ability to find gainful
employment okay it provides a very
challenging environment for us so let's
say we find somebody
and a DSP to come worked with our son
and great they develop a rapport with
their son a year fast forward great
everything's going fine two years come
along cost of living has gone up the
budget remains flat the only way we can
change that budget is by doing an
exception okay and the exceptions are
not put at the top of the list my
understandings are put further down the
list so it's likely we're not going to
receive that exception it's likely that
as two years experience or or more that
our DSP has developed
they're not going to get a livable wage
a working wage and they have to leave
okay so a very skilled person we
encourage them to get out of the system
because we're not going to increase your
rates okay that's that's what we're
facing and then what will happen is two
years okay we go through the whole
process again we have to find another
DSP it's going to take six months or so
there's an extreme Workforce shortage
problem right now
we have to find another DSP we have to
go the whole process all over again all
right so this bill I believe will help
address that maybe it's not going to
solve the problem but at least will help
cost of living uh your wages track the
cost of living okay so that's that's
where I stand so I I would encourage you
to support hb642 uh the other thing is
we have hb608 which we gave testimony on
a couple weeks ago that's about the BDS
system redesign looking the two-tier
waiver structure okay separate those
problems don't conflate these things
together don't join the BDS system
transformation with this bill these
things are separable problems okay so
don't don't set the success of this on
the success of this BDS system
transformation which is still undergoing
a change okay okay thank you
questions
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just I'm just trying
to understand the process and I'm
relatively new to it so so you you go
through all this work you you have a
provider you're comfortable but now the
cost of living goes up and you say you
you can't there's no way to amend the
budget you say except by applying for an
exemption is that what you said
exception exceptional yes yes so what's
involved in that and what are the kinds
of things that you can look to in the
exception okay so the the reason you
would need an exception is that if your
needs stay the same your service plan
stays the same so things haven't changed
which is you know probably pretty
typical okay so what do we do we work
with our area agency they help with
providing that exception I don't know
the exact machinations to make that
happen Okay but my understanding it's
it's not a guaranteed result
but the exception does not allow for
cost of living though um or it does or
we don't know
I'm sorry I can't answer definitively on
that I just I just think it's it's a
very challenging process and what this
bill would do would be able to at least
allow that to track without an exception
process okay thank you
other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
sir thank you for your time
also signed up to speak is Karen Blake
good morning good morning about three
minutes ma'am thank you very much
um thank you chairman McDonald and
members of the House Health and Human
Services oversight Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee I
am a little rusty it has been a while
since I have had the pleasure of
testifying in front of this committee
um again my name is Karen Blake I live
in North Woodstock New Hampshire
um for full disclosure I am also the
director of public policy for csni but
um today I'm speaking as a private
citizen
um I am in support of um
HB 642 this bill actually has you know
the two issues that the people
previously have discussed you know the
first issue is to ensure that there
isn't a future hourly rate cap for
direct support professionals and the
second is to address uh what is known as
Legacy budgets for the adult service
system
ensuring that there's no hourly rate cap
for direct service professionals will
help for some flexibility in hiring and
hopefully help retain direct support
professionals my understanding is the
rate cap for direct support
professionals was in the recent past
but the bigger issue at least as far as
I'm concerned is looking at Legacy
budgets
my understanding of how the system works
currently is that there are very
specific reasons you know that there's
funding you know you have your you know
T you know teens that are transitioning
onto the adult service system we have
you know someone coming new into the
state or being no newly noted in the
state I actually know of one individual
in my community
and then there has to be a significant
change so what I'm hoping that this this
committee will approve especially a part
of this bill is another way to increase
a budget if need be cost of living
or if there's inflation and as we've
seen in the last you know the last two
years inflation has gone up
significantly
um you know your dollars that that were
worth you know something a year ago is
not the same that's worth today I know
me and everyone else is struggling a lot
of times with you know all of the
day-to-day monthly income things that
have gone up
um you know and what the way that I
really kind of think about these Legacy
budgets is kind of like a fixed income
you know you you're on a fixed income
and your dollars today are not going to
be worth the same tomorrow
um so why is this important to me
um I am a family member
um I have a young person who is going to
be transitioning into the adult service
system
um I want to ensure that he and
individuals like him have the
flexibility to have a great hourly rate
to get a direct support professional
hold on to that direct support
professional but also in the future make
sure that there's enough money in his
budget to cover all of those expenses
um you know that he isn't going to be
fixed into
one budget and I know that there's a lot
going on with the BDS
um you know system of work and system
redesign and I I have to Echo what will
had said you know these are kind of
separate issues um you know into kind of
uh
okay I am I am actually all wrapped up
in closing I would like to say again to
support hb642 thank you for being
patient with me while I am very nervous
unexpectedly
thank you are you taking questions I
will any questions
seeing none okay thank you thank you
and since it's school vacation week
right
also signed up to speak is Jennifer
Bertrand
good morning good morning again you have
two minutes ma'am thank you good morning
chairman McDonald and members of the
House Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs committee my name is Jennifer
Bertrand and I live in Mount Vernon and
I am one of these families that we're
talking about today
this bill is really important and I
agree with Alex it is a really valuable
tool budget tool and it is long overdue
and we can't continue to wait to think
that there are even individuals who left
Laconia and 30 years later could have
the same budget is just not okay you
know this is a small community you get
to know a lot of other families and I
know many families that have had the
same budgets for more than five years
and some more than 10 years
um I'm a devoted parent and my daughter
Chloe experiences a significant
developmental disability she served by
gateways Community Services on the
developmental disability waiver and we
actually use a pdms model that means
that we don't hire a vendor per se pdms
stands for person directed managed
services so as the family I organize her
program I put out ads to hire people I
supervise those people evaluate those
workers provide training to those
workers a lot goes in when you bring on
a new worker like will had mentioned
um
given the fact that there is no
workable mechanism right now to increase
budgets for cost of living adjustments
that means that in order to increase my
DSP wages we have to realize fewer hours
of services so over time the family
continues to take on more and more and
more
responsibility my husband and I also
provide overnight care Chloe got up four
times last night she has a seizure
disorder significant intellectual and
developmental disability you know we're
partners with the state and we want to
do all that we can to ensure that she
can live a meaningful life in the
community and be as productive as
possible we also help to support her to
open her own little small business
there's some pictures on the back of my
testimony of Chloe working she likes to
have a sense of purpose
this is unsustainable my husband and I
while we're able to work remotely right
now
he's with her right now I'll have to be
with her this afternoon we work late
into the evening so 24 7. it's
caregiving and it's working so that we
can keep our jobs pay our bills and be
contributing members to society but this
can't last forever I'm getting older my
husband's getting older many families
are getting older it's my understanding
about 80 percent of individuals still
live at home with their families and and
those parents are aging and aren't
unable to do more and more sometimes
there's not like a specific change of
life circumstance but again if we don't
have this mechanism the budget stays the
same and the only way to increase your
DSP page is to get fewer hours of
services so I absolutely urge you to
pass this bill and create some way or a
mechanism so that can happen now I know
that
um
this may mean that some people would be
on a wait list it might create a legacy
wait list and you know we can definitely
work on that later but policy making is
iterative this is the first step to
seeing the problem it's not part of the
you know shouldn't be dependent on the
BDS system redesign there are some
serious concerns with the rate
methodologies that are being developed
and tying budgets to this supports
intensity scale and I have a lot of
questions as a family who takes that
pdms model
and I'm doing all this work to create
and manage her program
how those rates will affect families
like mine so I urge you to please
support this bill create the mechanism
this is one step in the right direction
and it's the right thing to do thank you
questions
anyone have any questions
okay thank you
no one else has signed up to testify on
House Bill 642 does anybody else wish to
testify
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 642 and
open the house of the public hearing on
House Bill 378 and recognize the prime
sponsor representative Reed
we have one
representative Reed we do need a pink
car at itself
okay thank you sorry no
uh thank you uh honorable chair and
honorable members of the committee uh
from the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 that's Newmarket
in new fields
the bill before you today simply
requires that a medical provider
and form a patient who may have been
drugged or assaulted of their existing
right to have evidence collected
and to restored as part of a state
assault kit
it does not create a new right that
right already exists in 21 colon m
I have distributed packets including the
current rsas regarding sexual assault
victims rights including the right to an
examination free of charge actually and
the right to have those kits and the
evidence and those kits collected
I'm going to tell the story of the
generation of this bill
on April 29 of last year a woman who
lives in my town of Newmarket was
sexually assaulted by a co-worker she
worked at a job that necessitated
staying overnight in a bunk house where
she had her own room
she went to a get-together of co-workers
after the shift in the community room of
the bunkhouse and after consuming a
drink that she had made herself
she discovered that an identical drink
had been placed in front of her while
she was not looking she knew that there
had only been one individual close
enough to her and handling the drinks
and he confirmed that he made the drink
trusting her co-workers she began to
drink the beverage however she only
consumed about a third of the drink
before she felt groggy and laid her head
on the table this was unusual as she
considers herself experienced in
drinking and well-versed and how her
body responds to drinking
she was woken by the sensation of the
same co-worker massaging her hand from
which she pulled away repeatedly when
she lifted her head she realized that
all the other co-workers had left and
she was alone with this one person
she felt ill and stood to go to the
bathroom but this co-worker grabbed her
by the arm and pulled her back into the
room to prevent her from leaving
she insisted she had to vomit but the
co-worker followed her into the single
stall bathroom and proceeded to grope
her sides and buttocks while she vomited
and urinated on herself
when she tried to remove his hands he
stated don't worry I don't care you're
puking I'm paying attention to your ass
when she was able to stop vomiting
temporarily she pushed him out of the
bathroom and closed and locked the door
but when she opened the door to leave
approximately 15 minutes later he was
blocking the door
she got past him and ran to her room and
managed to close the door in his face
and locked herself in the room he
continued to text her to try to convince
her to let him into the room which she
did not do
the next morning it was discovered that
the co-worker had cleaned all evidence
of what had happened including using so
much soap in the glass of the glass
smelled perfumed she was certain she was
drugged and she is certain to this day
that she was drugged
everything I have just told you was
testified to in court and found by the
judge to be the facts of the case and
the basis for a permanent protective
order which was issued by the judge
the next morning she was still sick and
called her husband to take her to
Wentworth Douglas hospital to be tested
she made it clear to all the health
professionals there that she had been
assaulted and believed she had been
drugged and that she was there to be
tested at one point the doctor asked but
were you assaulted when you were
assaulted
indicating that he did not understand
the definition of assault
the doctor refused to run the state
sexual assault kit because the patient
had been successful in getting away
and protecting herself and so had not
been penetrated the doctor only ran
tests for illicit recreational drugs
like cocaine and methamphetamines which
are stimulants that are never used for
date rape but do carry a stigma with
them
to be clear she was not showing any
symptoms of using such drugs and was not
in medical distress in a way consistent
with stimulant use if the woman had
happened to be a user of illicit drugs
her claims of assault would have been
cast into doubt however all of these
tests were negative
the woman who describes herself as a
fighter in a very outspoken and capable
very outspoken and capable of advocacy
even in a crisis was angry at the
doctor's refusal to run the state kit
and continued to insist that the doctor
run the appropriate tests so much so
that the doctor sent in a social worker
to calm her down
but he did not run the state test in any
evidence
that could have helped her was lost
I have to wonder how many victims have
not been nearly so vocal in advocating
for themselves as this woman was and
went away without ever knowing that they
had a right to a state kit
further best practice guidelines
indicate that medical providers should
call in Advocates or sane nurses that
sexual assault nurse examiners in cases
of sexual assault
and such Advocates would have known that
the woman was entitled to a state kid
this is strongly advised but not
mandatory
but because the doctor and none of the
nurses or the social worker correctly
identified either drugging or unwanted
sexual contact or attempted rape as
sexual assault even though they are
under our rsas
sexual offenses no sane nurse or
Advocate was called in
and here is where I have to explain uh
what I have found out in investigating
this issue uh there is a difference
between the tests that are available to
hospitals and the tests that are
available in the state assault kits we
commonly hear about the date rape drugs
GHB or Rohypnol or roofies these drugs
are famous for erasing victims memory
however I learned that they are not even
remotely the most common date rape drugs
GHB and Rohypnol have the downsides of
being illegal and therefore expensive
and difficult to obtain and problematic
if anyone finds them on a person
the most common date rape drugs after
alcohol itself are Benadryl and
over-the-counter sleep aids which
severely exacerbate the effects of
alcohol but are widely and cheaply
available and do not arouse suspicion if
someone is seen carrying them
these drugs are water soluble and have a
short half-life in the body the tests
for suspected drugging with these drugs
involve testing for very very low levels
of a metabolite of a metabolite of
metabolite
so there is no medical reason to test
for these Trace levels of metabolites
only a forensic reason therefore Labs
that hospitals have access to do not
offer these tests there are only a
handful of labs in the country that
offer these particular tests for Trace
levels of over-the-counter depressants
and they are used entirely by State Labs
across the country only only a state
sexual assault kit has access to these
tests
I contacted the hospital and the woman's
behalf and had a conference call with
the medical director the medical
director claimed that there was a state
rule that said that state kids could
only be run in cases of penetration
incredulous I contacted the AG's office
Victim Assistance unit the official at
the AG's office informed me that not
only did no such rule exist but the AG
sends out guidance and I found out later
it is actually RSA mandated guidance of
the AG sends out
and that is also in your packets two
medical providers which state the exact
opposite of what I was told by the
medical director I have distributed the
text of some of the texts from the
guidance it's quite extensive the
guidance asserts among other things that
a victim of any sexual offense which
includes drugging unwanted sexual
contact and attempted felonious or
aggravated felonious sexual assault AKA
what we would call rape
such as the woman in this case is
entitled in RSA 21m to a state assault
kit being collected and that she cannot
be denied access to that
it also asserts the kit may be collected
and samples stored anonymously with
instructions on proper storage giving
the victim at least 60 days to decide
whether to officially report the crime
and it furthers asserts that any part of
the kit may be collected individually
not all elements of the kit need to be
submitted
the Victim Assistance official at the
AG's office indicated to me repeatedly
and emphatically over two separate phone
calls that despite this AG guidance that
is distributed to preventical providers
there is an issue of medical medical
providers feeling to understand how to
correctly submit State kits and that
that problem was rampant
with many doctors not understanding not
only the definition of assault but that
not elements of a kit needs to be
submitted for example blood and urine
could be submitted without a swab
leading to the presumption that if there
is no need for a vaginal or other swab
that none of the kit can be collected or
submitted that is incorrect
um I also
contacted a number of organizations that
deal with uh Victim Advocacy and had
several Zoom calls I explained the
situation I'm sad to report that there
was some defensiveness some of the
participants were either authors of the
guidance themselves which the guidance
is fine or in charge of the same nurse
or Advocate programs and they seemed
concerned that my desire to make sure
that this particular crack that people
have been falling through according to
the AG
meant that I was either imputing the
guidance or that I was somehow going to
interfere with the sane or Advocate
programs they told me they liked things
the way they were and I criticized them
strongly for not advocating for the
victims they claim to defend when I
explained that the AG's office indicated
this was indeed a systematic problem
that kept happening they agreed that the
issue needed to be addressed I asked for
ideas on language but received none from
the organizations I believe there may be
bad feelings left between myself and the
organizations that may be preventing a
good faith effort resolving this issue
so now I will talk about the bill itself
because doctors clearly
um I'll say doctors meaning providers in
general clearly are having issues
understanding uh what the rights of the
the patient are that is why this bill is
needed it is simple and it is small it
is saying that providers will inform
victims who are asserting that they may
have been drugged or experienced
unwanted sexual touching or attempted
assault
of their right to have evidence
collected either stored or submitted as
part of a state kit it simply codifies
the core part of the AG guidance
so that medical providers can make sure
the victim is aware of their legal right
to a kit in any sexual offense
as I said the right already exists in
21m and the AG has to inform medical
providers of victims rights in a guide
so RSA says that the victims have this
right and RSA says the AG's office has
to provide information on those victims
rights to Medical providers but RSA does
not say that the medical providers or
really anyone has to inform the victim
of their right to a kid and if you've
just come out of trauma and you're in
the middle of a crisis and you're
expected to know what some obscure RSA
and fight for that and fight the entire
staff at the hospital for that right
I don't think that's right I think that
they should be notified of their rights
and the benefit of doing that is that in
so doing and making the doctors inform
the patients of their inherent right
that the doctor then becomes aware of
what the rights of the patient are and
that's really the point
it's important to note
that this in no way interferes with the
same program or Advocate Program which
is not mandatory but rather this better
helps providers to call in sane nurses
or Advocates by helping doctors
correctly identify assault this at least
establishes a floor for the medical
provider which currently does not exist
because all law and guidance has
presumed that medical providers would
have no problem identifying sexual
assault and would have no issues
administering a state kit when asked
that has not been the case
no fewer than three ER doctors were
consulted on this bill and all of them
stated this was not problematic
requirement so long as notification
could be given by a nurse or signed off
on by a form which it certainly can
there's no language in here that
prevents that foreign
and then the only thing I will say is
I've emailed before is that there was an
incorrect title uh put out by OLS from a
previous version of the bill the title
implies that the medical provider would
do the storing that is not the normal
way of doing things usually medical
providers contact law enforcement and
the law enforcement does the appropriate
storage that is not in the bill it's
simply an incorrect title I have also
distributed the amendment you don't have
to adopt the amendment because obviously
the title doesn't affect the RSA at all
but I wanted to make sure that you had
the correct Amendment
and I will close by asking the committee
to please take this seriously I know a
lot of bills in the state house in my
six years here I've seen a lot of them
get dismissed over
small errors or you know no one really
wanting to work on it
and and good ideas sometimes fall
through but this is a significant Gap in
our current system and there's no excuse
for this Gap to exist if there is
language that the committee this
committee feels that better suits
meeting this need I'm happy to help the
committee in getting an amendment
drafted for example if you feel that a
penalty is appropriate or if you feel
the inclusion of other information
beyond the right to a estate kit is
appropriate but at a bare minimum there
needs to be accountability that the
provider know what sexual assault is and
know if they are violating the existing
right that those victims have by denying
them a kit and with that all attempt to
take questions
any questions
representative profile yes thank you for
your testimony and thank you for taking
my question so in the in the Attorney
General's guidance there is some
considerable content about Anonymous
kits
so
understanding that the bill as it is
written right now is fairly simple do
you think it is appropriate that that
notification requirement be extended to
include notification that there is also
a right to an anonymous kit so if a
woman should decide
at a later date that that
um
she wants to pursue
criminal charges or an investigation do
you think it would be appropriate to add
that to the bill or is there any
downside to doing that I thank you for
the question representative I don't see
any downside I considered it but I
wanted to keep it as simple as possible
to help ensure passage if this committee
feels which I think would be totally
appropriate uh the to include the
information that a victim and I'll say a
victim rather than a woman but that a
victim
may have the dis has the decision
already it already exists whether or not
to immediately report it through law
enforcement or to have their evidence
collected right then and there because
if they wait the evidence is gone
and they can they through the current
procedure as you pointed out they can
have their evidence collected and stored
at least for 60 days and they can
petition to have it stored longer while
they make the decision and that's
collected anonymously while they make
the decision of whether or not to pursue
it legally
but yes I think it would be appropriate
to add it absolutely
thank you questions representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for being here today my apologies I
don't have RSA 21-m in front of me but
we're talking about Healthcare Providers
here is this only in reference to ER
doctors or is this also a requirement
for all pcps and Specialists and what
what is the scope of these Healthcare
Providers thank you so the thank you for
the question it is all medical providers
because we can't say for sure who a
victim would report to or go to for
assistance but the vast vast majority of
providers that this would actually apply
to our ER providers so
having said that you can't tell a future
victim that they only have the right to
that notification if they go to the ER
and not to their primary or not to an
urgent care or not to wherever
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um as a follow-up to this question what
would be the penalty for not being aware
number one and therefore not providing
the option to a victim to have this kid
supplied to them
so there is no penalty in the bill as I
said I kept it as minimal as possible to
help increase its chances of Passage I
would support a penalty there I looked
through 21 and there's no penalty for
any of the other requirements of medical
providers and there are quite a few
requirements of medical providers in
these cases
so another follow-up in
which I agree with it entirely in its in
its premise
um
if you ask all providers to provide the
opportunity
um to the victim to have a kid would you
be opposed to amending it for the two
others who may make direct contact with
the victim say law enforcement somebody
that they may not go to that you know
they may not go to the hospital they may
not see a primary care but they may call
law enforcement should that be extended
to them as well it absolutely could be
and and I personally think should be
again I I was really shooting for the
the lowest bare minimum standard that we
should be expecting but I would be happy
to extend it to law enforcement if the
committee saw fit
thank you other questions
I'm seeing none okay thank you thank you
also signed up to testify uh Lynn Chalet
and Janet Carroll from the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence
and three minutes a piece ladies
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Lynn schillette I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence we are the umbrella
Organization for the 12 community-based
crisis centers in New Hampshire who
provide free and confidential services
to approximately 15 000 victims a year
we also are the home for the Statewide
sexual assault nurse examiner program
and I am joined by one of the
co-directors today
I wanted to share with you that when we
hand in our testimony today we will also
be submitting to the committee a letter
uh that we joined with a number of other
organizations in opposition to this bill
and I just wanted to draw your attention
to it that in addition to our Coalition
it has been signed by the New Hampshire
Hospital Association they are here today
the New Hampshire Medical Association
the New Hampshire nurse practitioner
Association and the New Hampshire
Society of physician assistants we all
share similar concerns about this bill
so with that I'd like to introduce you
to Janet Carroll our sane program
co-director thank you
good morning Mr chairman
member directors of the of the sexual
assault nurse examiner program at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence I'm also a nurse
manager of one of the busiest forensic
nursing programs in New Hampshire in my
career I have completed more than a
thousand sexual assault medical forensic
evaluations and I'm here today to speak
in opposition of house bill 378.
we are sincerely sorry that a negative
experience led to this bill okay while
we support the overall intention of this
legislation to ensure that patients are
offered all options available to them we
have some significant concerns
specifically this bill goes against
current practices and protocols already
in place in New Hampshire that have been
carefully developed over time
the first the state of New Hampshire
already has a protocol in place for the
medical forensic evaluations of sexual
assault patients in the health care
setting this protocol has existed for
several decades and is posted and
followed at all New Hampshire hospitals
Health Care Providers throughout the
state are educated on the on the
protocol and Best Care processes it puts
in place for the care of patients who
have experienced sexual assault
the current protocol is written and
revised regularly by the
multi-disciplinary expert members of the
New Hampshire sexual assault insane
Advisory Board the protocol and
complementary sexual assault survivors
Bill of Rights are well written with a
trauma-informed victim-centered lens
that makes them sensitive to the
patient's needs currently within the
protocol there is already a section
specific to drug facilitated sexual
assault if a patient presents reporting
being drugged and reports that a sexual
assault did occur or might have occurred
there is a process in place which
involves collection of blood and or
urine samples if the drugging occurred
within a specific time frame those
samples are then turned over to law
enforcement with the jurisdiction for
storage preservation and Analysis if
appropriate
second if a patient reports a concern
that they have been drugged and states
there is no chance of sexual assault
occurred a sexual assault evidence
collection kit would not be warranted
because a sexual assault did not occur
in those circumstances there would be a
discussion between the patient and the
medical provider on the medical need for
testing if any and if so what drug
testing options might be available and
appropriate
those decisions would be made on a
case-by-case basis and the medical need
of the patient
many drugs have limited lifespans and
may only be detectable for four hours
after ingestion in addition if the
patient reports being drugged as a crime
to law enforcement there are additional
legal processes already in place for the
law enforcement agencies to obtain those
samples from the hospital laboratory at
their discretion I believe there's other
he's here today to testify to that in
summary we are in opposition of this
bill we believe the protocols already in
place serve the needs of sexual assault
victims in our states and that patients
would like to receive
who would like to receive blood in urine
tests have options available to them
already thank you and I'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you questions representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh could you tell me
the overall situation around sexual
assault kid processing in New Hampshire
um I heard that in some other areas
nationally there's some backlog of
processing those kids is there any issue
of backlog processing in New Hampshire
and do you see this bill
might create or make it worse if it will
be more kids
distributed and need to process them do
you see any problem with that thank you
I believe they're individuals here from
the Department of Safety who might be
more appropriate to respond to that
question if you'd like to hold it
representative does that make sense
thank you thank you
other questions representative pushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um can you share with the committee what
um in in your protocol what the
definition of sexual assault is does it
only include penetration Does it include
unwanted touching and Does it include
drugging
so I believe that question would be best
for the legal folks within our our
programs but
um
there are several definitions within the
protocol
um
and they reference other statutes in the
state
follow up
thank you would you be able to provide
the committee with um like a digital
copy copy of that protocol and Bill of
Rights that you mentioned
thank God absolutely thank you
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
both for being here would you include in
the definition of sexual assault
attempted rape and fondling
again that would be for uh legal folks
sorry I was just trying to do that
because that is on the domestic violence
Coalition website as the definition and
I'm curious about that mismatch if those
are not treated with this level of
severity
thank you representative mask a
clarifying question it seems like the
questions that you all are asking right
now is whether or not evidence would be
collected if a patient presented saying
they'd been sexually assaulted but it
was not a penetration crime is that
that is 100 correct so Janet do you want
to speak to the what the response would
be yeah um so generally if a sexual
assault evidence collection kit would be
collected if we suspected somebody
else's DNA on their bodies were their
acts occurred that that led to that
um
in terms of a drugging
I wouldn't necessarily call someone in
for an Evidence collection kit
um without other acts that have occurred
we don't know what that potential
drugging might have been for and that
would be up to law enforcement to decide
I think I can add a clarifying um piece
of information if someone presented an
emergency room with injuries and perhaps
they had been bitten on their breasts or
their buttocks and there's a possibility
that there could be saliva that would be
collected absolutely that evidence would
have been collected and it would have
been treated as a sexual assault for
purposes of collecting evidence
follow-up sorry and then as a follow-up
so if a woman is a woman or a man is
successful in defeating the attempted
rape and there's no DNA transferred you
believe it do you believe it's
inappropriate to collect blood and urine
samples
could you repeat that I'm sorry thank
you if a man or a woman is successful in
stopping an attempted rape so that there
is not a DNA transfer do you think that
it is inappropriate use of resources to
collect the the urine or blood samples
I wouldn't feel that it would be
appropriate to collect those at that
time
thank you
other questions
representative Missouri
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um so I read through your testimony and
I noticed in there that it said this
legislation if passed would result in
several unintended consequences can you
elaborate a little bit on what those
might be
um
some so
in terms of unintended consequences a
lot of people would think that a blutter
urine test is the end-all be-all
um
not necessarily they have a half-life of
some we have a half-life of four hours
or in are in and out of the system that
quickly if the urine sample is not
placed on Ice would there be a chain of
custody issue possibly
um
sometimes they will have false negatives
come back several states do not even
test for drug facilitated sexual assault
as part of their evidence collection kit
because they would provide you know
false sense of security that something
didn't happen or that something may have
happened
um
often they will go based on the signs
and symptoms that that person
experienced during or or with the
complete lack of injury I mean complete
lack of memory of what occurred
thank you for the question
representative another concern that we
have is this bill would mandate every
medical provider to offer a test to
anyone who presents for any of these
crimes the victim has a choice to turn
that down our concern would be if a
victim didn't want to be tested for one
reason or another perhaps they're
underage and they've been drinking
perhaps they did use an illegal
substance that they're declining the
test would actually be used against them
in the prosecution of their case so this
is an overbroad mandate by a long shot
in terms of who medical providers would
be required to notify
that's very helpful thank you
yes representative Lanza
uh would all
um providers be educated in regards to
this process of what they need to do
when a victim of assault has come into
their office
I'm going to talk about the internet
um The Physicians Advanced providers and
what have you when they go through like
part of their orientation process at the
hospital would be to include going over
what would occur if this partic you know
if a particular patient presented with
this specific Chief complaint
can I follow up follow up and would um
where would they have those kits within
their offices in order to
um you know get the samples yep so um
specifically these uh the sexual assault
evidence collection kits are kept in
emergency departments in the state of
New Hampshire so if a patient presented
to an office clinic or to an urgent care
or some other setting than the emergency
department they are then you know given
a warm handoff to the emergency
department that's closest to them
representative Murphy thank you um and
thank you for taking my question um just
a question how long have these kits been
available and do they change in time as
far as what's in the kit
uh yes
um so oh gosh the first kit was in the
90s when it was developed we're in the
9000 Series kit
um with each one thousand kits we go
through with a multi-disciplinary team
that includes you know law enforcement
medical providers advocacy crime lab
personnel and what have you and they go
through what is the next best
evidence-based practice
and that's how these are developed and
changed each time
thank you
representative King thank you chairman
McDonald thank you for taking questions
I can understand the um apprehension
with requiring every medical
professional professional to do
something that maybe is
just Overkill but you know as a as a
victim there's got to be somewhere a
person can go to collect as much
evidence as possible for a future legal
action I mean it would be it just seems
devastating the idea that somebody could
fall through this the cracks like that
where would a person go right now if
they said no I'm getting this this test
done now I don't care what anybody else
says I want it now where would they go
if not the ER or somewhere else so
um I believe our partners will talk to a
regarding that those exact same tests
that would be collected as part of like
the kit law enforcement could also do
that as well but they'll they'll talk
about all that
um
hospitals also have other means yes they
have the general toxicology panel
um
some places will also do hair toxicology
if it's been greater than three weeks
since the time of the ingestion some
places will send out what's called a
headed sedative hypnotic panel each
Hospital does have additional testing
that they are able to complete if they
feel it's appropriate in the medical
need
but follow up by the way but you're
still dependent on somebody else giving
you permission to take that test I mean
there's got to be somewhere a victim to
go without anybody else's permission in
the entire world to take that test I
mean so is there right now or or do you
still at this day need permission from
somebody else to get that test thank you
it would
um and again if it warranted they could
do this as part of a kit otherwise law
enforcement could potentially as well
um have that that testing done
um
otherwise I'm unaware at dhmc we do a
sedative hypnotic panel which does
include Rohypnol GHB and several other
drugs
other questions
representative Freitas yes I have a
question can I purchase one of those
kits from my personal use no you cannot
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here and
taking my question does that sedative
hypnotic panel typically also check for
Benadryl metabolites or no it does not
other okay
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much
also signed up to speak is Jade flad
vilardi
good morning good morning hi hi you have
about three minutes ma'am three minutes
okay so
um I am
here today of in favor of this bill
never done anything like this and this
is literally my worst nightmare sitting
here talking to a bunch of strangers so
bear with me
um
when I saw this bill when
you know
I can't think of when this
I can't think of names now
um when I saw this bill and talked to
Leanne and about this it really struck a
chord with me
um I am
a New Hampshire right through and
through I was born here lived here my
whole life and even after college when I
met my husband from New York I made him
move here to be in New Hampshire you
know the Live Free or Die State
um
when I see a bill like this coming up
because somebody has a personal
experience that was so awful that they
felt like they needed to bring it up to
this level of you know people who can
help you because the people who should
be helping you or not I think is just a
little bit crazy
um
opposing this bill to me
screams you're just
here to protect rapists to protect
pedophiles to protect the people
committing these crimes and not helping
these actual victims because what woman
wants to come in somewhere
she's
all shaken up she has no idea what's
happening like she wants to throw up
because she's been violated and
people want to make
them
bit
these incredibly specific criteria when
this is a human being this is most
likely a teenage girl you know a young
adult
that has no idea what to do has never
been to a hospital without her parents
ever and now she's in the situation
where she's seeking help for the crisis
that now she's experiencing and
on the other side of it
she could get pushed back saying well we
don't think what happened to you was an
actual assault
and the Damage that can do to a person
um I don't know if you've seen the
statistics lately
The Washington Post just
um posted this crazy statistic saying
American Girls in high school right now
one in three have seriously considered
suicide
that's insane to me like these girls are
getting to a point where they would
rather kill themselves than
try to keep going in this society that
literally is giving us nothing we're
losing women are losing everything and
now
a simple Bill like this like hey can we
get more rape kits and more places and
make sure it's easier for these victims
to to get these sort of things so they
can pursue Justice if they want to for
them to begin the healing Journey that
absolutely is going to take years for
them to recover from
um I feel like those essential moments
when a woman comes in and needs help and
mayor said something like that's not
protocol for what you've experienced
like
how can you be a human being
and think that not every single person
who's experiencing some sort of sexual
assault
should have access to the testing and
the health care that they think they
need in order to heal and move forward
with this
um
that's all I can think of I mean I you
know it just really scares me
I don't know a single woman who has not
encountered some sort of sexual
harassment or abuse I'm a childhood
um
I'm a Survivor of childhood sexual
assault and I'm 35 now and literally to
this day
nobody knows because I didn't know who
to tell I didn't know what to do
as I got older I saw that it's not just
me experiencing these scary ordeals and
I still don't know what to do I have two
little girls who you know they're eight
and six
am I gonna have to prepare them for when
you are sexually assaulted this is what
we have to do and you've got to make
sure you have your story right because
they're going to turn you away otherwise
like that just feels insane like what
are we
thank you ma'am
thank you for listening to me are you
taking questions or I would love to
answer any questions
I have questions
so thank you would you believe that we
all thank you very much for coming and
sharing this yeah yeah thank you I I
have experience
sort of thing and I am really excited to
be here to say these things to people
who are making these choices so thank
you for having me thank you for coming
and I hope that you know these
testimonies help you make a good
decision hi representative
I would just like you to share this with
people who can learn from your
experience and I thank you so much for
coming out for today your courage thank
you
also signed up to speak is Jennifer
Bosco Webb
good morning good morning yeah three
minutes ma'am please
I don't know if can you okay yeah you
can hear me hi I'm Jennifer Bosco Webb
also haven't done this before so forgive
me
um I just have some statistics and
thoughts on the providing the rape kits
which I am
um
I think it's very important to provide
them to any sexual assault Survivor
um every 68 seconds an American is
sexually assaulted every nine minutes
that victim is a child one in six women
have experienced at least one sexual
assault in their lifetime
one in 33 men will as well
these statistics are just those that are
reported
according I just wanted to clear up when
in listening to the women who were
opposed of this bill and there was some
question as to what sexual assault is
defined as I did a quick Google search
um
because I have an idea
but I wanted to make sure I got it right
According to rain.org which is the rape
abuse and incest national network the
term sexual assault refers to the sexual
contact or behavior that occurs without
explicit consent of the victim
some forms of sexual assault include
attempted rape fondling or unwanted
sexual touching forcing a victim to
perform sexual acts such as oral sex or
penetrating the perpetrator's body
penetration of the victim's body also
known as rape
only 25 of every 1000 Predators will end
up serving time in prison DNA evidence
can increase the likelihood of holding
perpetrators accountable and prevent
other attacks rate kits provide this
evidence
rape kits gather clothing fibers hair
bodily fluids that could be used to
convict these perpetrators and bodily
fluids
survivors who endure the intrusive and
extensive steps to have DNA evidence
stored to be tested which can take about
four to six hours
um
sorry identify unknown performing these
rape kits help to identify unknown
assailants solve crimes reveal serial
offenders and exonerate wrongfully
convicted in unveiling criminal patterns
statistically assailants
it is not their first time and it will
not be their first time
so if we can prevent that I don't
understand why we would try to stop that
um
in a fun little fact that I found on the
endthebacklog.org
was in addition to increasing safety
communities save money by testing and
providing kits and Prosecuting offenders
in Cuyahoga County Ohio officials tested
over 7 000 backlogged kits investigated
every lead engaged survivors in
prosecuted cases through this testing
serial criminals were taken off the
streets and future crimes were averted
saving the county an estimated 38
million dollars you could begin wrapping
up ma'am please sure if you take a look
around the room as I mentioned before at
least one in six women here have
experienced sexual assault in their
lifetime 33 men have as well and every
nine minutes one of those victims is a
child every single one of these victims
deserve to have tests readily available
to provide at least any semblance of
safety after such a traumatic experience
um just a quick note I am a survivor of
sexual assault and I
was not given the opportunity to
have a rape kit performed
and I wish more than anything that I
could have because
as I am learning from other individuals
who have also been victims of my
assailant
what if a rape kit could have stopped
him and prevented the so far six other
victims of this perpetrator
um I just I it's very important to the
safety of the community and yeah
any questions any questions
okay no questions thank you very much
for coming in
also signed up to speak is Michelle
Sanborn
good morning
thank you for hearing this bill and um
yeah considering
the significance of the implication of
what this great minutes ma'am if you can
simple bill will accomplish thank you my
name is Michelle Sanborn I'm from
Belmont New Hampshire
um in my 20s I was a victim of sexual
assault I'm now in my 50s
that experience never leaves you was I
raped no
so would a rape Kip do me any good no
would the expanded what I would consider
and this is my verbiage understanding of
this is more of a toxicology report
versus an actual rape kid that is
looking for DNA this would have helped
me I wasn't bit on the buttocks I wasn't
bit on the breast there was no DNA
transfer it doesn't mean that my
experience was any less
significant than any other woman or
person
um
I heard earlier from and I don't know
the exact name of the organization but
domestic violence organization
that this would mandate collection of
samples that could incriminate a victim
potentially
the way I read this it says requiring a
health care provider to inform and offer
doesn't force a victim to do anything
it doesn't force a health care provider
to do anything other than inform and
offer leaving the choice to the victim
I wanted to clarify that
if I had had the choice I would have
opted for this kind of testing
I didn't have that choice
I have a 23 year old daughter who
currently could be in a position where
she may not have that choice
I've been to a number of Health Care
providers in my life many of us have
that have often not been willing to
perform procedures
that I was interested in learning more
about didn't mean I was going to jump in
and do it it meant I wanted more
information
and they were unwilling to provide that
information on something that wasn't
even this significant
so we look to our health care providers
as symbols of authority
that's the structure of our culture and
our society and what we're conditioned
and trained to believe like teachers and
and police officers
so if a healthcare provider doesn't
believe that it's warranted that person
will never receive the information or
they'll run up against resistance and a
rejection a denial
that's not a right
that's not fair it's not even
human Humane if you will
people should at least have the right to
be informed and in my view that's what
this bill is accomplishing it's not me
and dating anything other than
those that we look to in Authority as
protection figures are mandated to at
least offer and inform
and I think that's the very least that
could be done
I'm open to questions thank you
questions
see no questions okay thank you ma'am
thank you
also signed up to speak is Alex Lee from
the Newport Police Department
good morning good morning Mr chairman
good morning members of the committee
again if you could keep your testimony
around three minutes yes sir my name is
Alex Lee I'm the chief of police in
Newport until about three weeks ago I
was a specialized sexual assault
investigator for the last 19 years
I come before you this morning I support
the intention behind this bill but I
have serious concerns and I have to
oppose the specific language related to
toxicology samples and the reason why is
because I believe that the language of
this bill will have serious unintended
consequences
sexual assault is a crime and the
investigation of sexual assault is very
complex in these cases law enforcement
and prosecution has to discuss together
and decide together what evidence should
and should not be collected what
evidence will or will not be helpful
towards a prosecution in order to hold
offenders accountable and those
discussions take place on a case-by-case
basis
in some cases a toxicology sample from a
Survivor is very important and helpful
evidence in a prosecution
in those cases law enforcement already
has protocols in place and the ability
to request a legal blood draw from a
Survivor or to request already taken
samples from a hospital for evidentiary
purposes
those Protocols are in place and working
here in New Hampshire
the first unintended consequence of this
bill in my opinion is that in many cases
depending on the drug involved and
depending on the time frames of
ingestion The Taking of a toxicology
sample which is outside of our
established protocols may actually be
harmful to a prosecution
the second unintended consequence of
this bill in my opinion is related to
storage Hospital toxicology labs are not
equipped to store samples in a legal
chain of custody manner police
departments and the New Hampshire State
Police forensic lab also do not have the
space available to store a large influx
of new samples taken outside of the
established protocols for up to in some
cases 40 years as may be required
the third unintended consequence of this
bill in my opinion is related to testing
many hospitals as well as the New
Hampshire State Police forensic lab do
not have the ability to test for many
substances that are commonly used in
drug facilitated sexual assaults for
this reason when law enforcement is
working on a case of a drug facilitated
sexual assault where a toxicology sample
has been taken we have to send that
sample to a private lab in Pennsylvania
at a cost of approximately one thousand
dollars per test
we use that tool routinely when we along
with prosecution believe that it will be
helpful for a prosecution
for these reasons I ask you to find that
this bill is inexpedient to legislate in
its current form I thank you for your
time and I'm happy to answer your
questions including maybe some of the
questions that came up earlier that were
not able to be answered
thank you yes representative King thank
you chairman thank you chairman McDonald
thank you for being here today
um this is very interesting because
I think that
there is a problem around the idea of
sexual assault so we we know it's
illegal just to drug somebody even if
there is no sexual assault whatsoever
right you can't just Spike somebody's
drink and even if there's no sexual you
just can't do that so but if a victim
goes into a hospital and they say it's
sexual assault but there is no other you
know DNA evidence or anything like that
then there's this weird protocol
loophole that prevents or allows for the
prevention of taking a drug test but if
the same victim were to go in there and
just say I got drug no sexual assault it
seems like there probably is some way
for them to be like oh let's test for
that so so you're telling me that if
somebody were to go in there and say
there was no sexual assault I was just
drugged without you know my consent they
can test for that but if you say and
there was sexual assault then they say
oh now I'm sorry that you you're in a
loophole we can't test now anymore so so
what is a person to do here it seems
like there's this weird loophole where
you know you just if if there's sexual
assault but there's no other DNA
evidence you'll get denied a test but if
it's just you know if it's just you were
drugged without your consent then they
will test you because I have a hard time
imagining that if a person right now
goes to a hospital and says I was
drugged without my consent that they're
going to say no we're not going to test
you of course they're going to test you
so why wouldn't they test you in this
other other case too thank you thank you
for your question and I can only speak
from the law enforcement perspective but
if a person comes into a police
department or a hospital but in some way
reports to law enforcement that they've
been drugged that is a crime and law
enforcement can request a legal blood
draw from a medical professional for
evidentiary purposes whether or not that
drugging was related to a sexual assault
the specific evidence collection within
a sexual assault kit is based on a
variety of different factors in every
sexual assault examination may result in
different types of evidence being
collected and different types of
evidence being tested depending on the
specific facts of that case so in many
cases
some cases a full kit is appropriate
some cases a partial kit but we are
going to tailor the evidence collection
to what would actually be helpful to a
prosecution so in a case where somebody
may have been drugged there may have
been an attempted sexual assault which
is a very serious crime that we take
seriously but where there may not be DNA
evidence available to collect law
enforcement can request a toxicology
sample in coordination with prosecution
as well as using other law enforcement
Tools in that investigation such as
victim interviews collection of digital
forensic evidence off of mobile devices
recorded one-party telephone calls so we
have a whole tool belt of tools to deal
with attempted sexual assaults drug
facilitated assaults but not every case
calls for the specific evidence
collection in the kit and not every
single case even which might have been
suspected to involve drugs not in every
case would a toxicology sample be
helpful the example that I use is in a
case where we believe that the drug was
in adjusted outside of the scientific
Windows where it would test positive
taking that sample and creating a
laboratory report that shows negative
for all substances would actually be
harmful in the prosecution of that case
so we try to tailor what evidence we're
collecting to the specific facts of each
case in front of us
follow up
my apologies I just I'm I'm struggling
to understand it seems like you're
putting the car before the horse a
little bit I mean it seems like the very
first thing you do is just collect all
the evidence possible you worry about
the prosecution later I mean there's not
a prosecute there's no attorney general
in the hospital representative King I
think he's basically just following
protocols that have been given to you
right yes and respectfully I I disagree
there uh if you collect all of the
evidence without regard to what evidence
is probative in other words what
evidence will establish guilt or
innocence uh that that unnecessary
collection of evidence that will not be
probative can be used by for example
defense counsel at a trial as sort of a
red herring to say look the state has
accused my client of a drug facilitated
sexual assault and this Toxicology test
shows no drugs in the victim system
therefore you know my client is not
guilty when we know that in many cases
based on the type of drug and the time
frames of ingestion a laboratory report
would not normally show positive for
that specific substance
thank you for your question
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
chief for being here
um my question is
um basically getting a little deeper
into that time frame it are there known
standards about what the half-life and
what the testing protocol is and would a
negative result for something with a
very short half-life be what the
expected result is if you were drugged
with say Benadryl
yes and I can't speak to the specific
half-life for Benadryl or any other
specific drug as I'm not a chemist or a
toxicologist however depending on the
drug and the half-life involved there
are going to be uh expected time frames
in which it would be positive or
negative also based on the amount of the
drug too and the limits of detection and
so the Attorney General's protocol for
evidence collection and the forensic
Labs protocol for their lab
accreditation is all based around the
best science available for time frames
of collection and that's not specific to
just toxicology samples that's uh that
is applicable to other types of forensic
evidence as well
well thank you um and then as a
follow-up are those evidence protocols
limited by storage space and is this
something where we're potentially not
collecting evidence that we should have
and is this something we should take to
um the budget or others so that we can
actually make sure that crimes in New
Hampshire are appropriately prosecuted
no the the protocols and the forensic
Labs Protocols are based on the best
scientific literature that's available
as far as uh the lab equipment that's
available and the types of results that
can be expected of different types of
testing it's not based on storage space
um previously you'd said that some
evidence was not collected because of
storage space so that's is that a
correct statement or not a correct
statement and I'm not trying to accuse
you of anything I'm just trying to get
to the bottom of this sure what what I
was trying to suggest is that
um an unintended consequence of this
bill is that evidence may be need
required hired to be collected and
stored under this bill that is not going
to be used for a prosecution and so it
will increase the requirements of our
storage space for evidence that is not
going to be
um helpful to a prosecution that's what
I was intending to say thank you
other representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um we heard in in
the prime sponsors opening testimony uh
a case of a woman who went and
desperately was trying to have a kit
collected and you know there was a
refusal so
um I would like to think that as part of
the discussions as to whether or not you
go forward with that not only is it
going to be the medical staff and the
law enforcement but I'm hoping that the
the victim has a voice in that
discussion as well but oftentimes we
have protocols Protocols are
misunderstood because law enforcement
are only human beings medical staff for
only human beings so in a case where a
victim feels that guess what I don't
think you understand the protocol you
may be law enforcement I really don't
think you understand the protocol what
modes of redress are available to a
person in that case
thank you for your question I do sit on
the Attorney General's sexual assault
insane Advisory Board and we have robust
discussions at all of our meetings about
specific cases we have discussions about
uh whether or not the protocol should be
amended to create new best practices as
new situations arise we also have robust
discussions about whether additional
training is needed for medical providers
for law enforcement for prosecution so
we do that on an ongoing basis and so as
situations arise where perhaps a
provider or a law enforcement officer
has not followed protocol then we will
establish training memorandums or uh
ongoing continuing education to ensure
that everybody involved in the system is
following the protocol going forward
follow-up and you know and so I I do
respect that answer and I do think you
know that we do have to when mistakes do
happen take a step back learn from it
but I don't know that that answer
necessarily addresses the individual in
that case who is saying I think that
you're not adhering to the protocol is
there anything that we have in the
moment aside from a follow-up review to
say you know what
you want to have a kind of an appeal of
sorts yeah I can go and I can get a
second ruling on that is there any
mechanism like that that exists because
a victim may not want to wait to have a
review board come back and say yeah
protocols were violated we need to
retrain many people will want to have
redress in the moment so I just want to
get your thoughts on that I appreciate
your question and I uh appreciate the
point behind it that it's too late
sometimes to close the door after the
horse has left the barn that being said
I I do think that in many situations
when a report is made to law enforcement
there is a discussion at the time
between law enforcement the medical
provider and prosecution while
Consulting with the protocol to
determine uh what the best course is
going forward with respect to situations
that are not reported to law enforcement
and this is only a conversation between
the patient and the medical provider I
can't really speak to that because I'm
not privileged of those discussions
thank you representative Bill King
thank you Mr chairman and also thank you
officer Lee for taking this question at
the very beginning of your testimony you
mentioned that you were in support of
the intent but not of the way it's
written so can you offer up some ideas
on how this bill would be amended to
your liking
I I support the intent of notifying
victims of their rights that
um are already in statute and already in
the Attorney General's protocol and uh
that should be in place already and
um but my concerns are specific to the
requirement to offer a Toxicology test
and my concerns are specific to that
because a Toxicology test is not always
helpful to an investigation and
prosecution and in fact is sometimes
harmful depending on the fact so I don't
think that we should always offer a
toxicology sample in cases where it is
not going to move an investigation or a
prosecution forward
thank you again chairman McDonald
um I think you're getting to the Crux of
the issue here which is you know forcing
providers to provide something that they
think is specious but at the end of the
day you still have a victim who doesn't
think it's specious
please tell me there must be somewhere a
person can go can they go to the local
CVS and say give me a drug test and just
hold on to that bottle maybe in a future
day I'll come get you I mean or is there
lit I mean you can get your blood tested
for DNA to find out you know your
ancestry come on there's got to be a way
to get your blood tested for you know
drugs in your system
where where can they go right now if if
everybody else is saying no we're not
going to do that because of some weird
protocol there's got to be somewhere
they can go even if they pay out of
pocket come on tell me thank you
there are private
um phlebotomists that could draw
somebody's blood there are independent
private Laboratories that can conduct
blood tests however I I don't support
generally uh private parties going that
route as opposed to reporting to law
enforcement because those tests do not
uh follow the chain of custody
guidelines and very well may not be
admissible in any kind of Court
proceeding whether some civil or
criminal so you know my suggestion is
that victims report to law enforcement
so that we can make sure that the
procedures are followed and that the
evidence is collected in a legally
defensible way
representative Cannon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
we'll talk about protocols
if if a victim not knowing that they
probably should go to the police first
goes to an ER room and
let some know that they've been
sexually assaulted or maybe a drug rape
type situation is there a protocol as
far as time frame for getting that
decision from a prosecutor or whatever
to take a sample
um and how long how long between them
getting into the ER or even into the
police department how long a period of
time does it take to get that decision
that a blood sample should be taken in
the majority of sexual assault cases
that we investigate the victim actually
does present to the ER often before the
police and the police department
responds to the ER to begin the pro the
investigation there
so if the beginning the investigation at
that time would there be a request to
take a toxicology
um test yeah and again it depends on the
specific circumstances but if I
responded to the ER and a victim said I
was I believe that I was drugged and
they described feeling the effects of
impairment from a potential drug and
that they believed there was an
attempted sexual assault but an assault
that was not completed then
um I would I have a canister with blood
tubes in it that I carry in my cruiser
and I would request the victim's consent
to have the medical staff draw a legal
blood draw for me with the victim's
consent and then I would submit it to
the appropriate lab for testing
thank you representative Cushman
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
where does that leave
victims who are not ready to go to the
police
who may be in the situation that the
woman that we heard about in the
introduction of the bill
um would find themselves in where does
that leave them
uh where that leaves us is that the
medical provider should follow the
Attorney General's protocol that's
already in place that specifies when a
toxicology sample should or should not
be collected
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
being here uh for us uh does New
Hampshire has a backlog of processing
this kit
New Hampshire has traditionally had a
backlog however uh we have obtained
grant funding and that backlog is being
quickly eliminated as we speak
thank you
um uh you were talking about
requirements for storage space and that
um
um if there will be excessive new flow
of kids
7bn app storage can you give me some
percentage of how much of storage is
currently utilized with current flow is
it close to 100 percent can we increase
at five percent some estimate please
currently law enforcement storage is
designed to temporarily store a sample
until it is submitted to the appropriate
lab and tested so a majority of smaller
police departments have essentially a
college dorm style mini fridge to hold
samples for a short period of time until
they are delivered to the lab larger
police departments like mine have
essentially a standard kitchen size
refrigerator no police departments that
I'm aware of have large industrial
walk-in cooler style refrigerators to
store you know hundreds of samples for
years or decades as might be
contemplated under this system
thank you other representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you from
the facts that you heard earlier on
about the constituent do you think that
that was an error on the healthcare
providers from not offering that sample
from what you heard
it that is a difficult question for me
to answer because I wasn't
um you know privy to the facts of that
case as they were happening
um so I really hesitate to speculate on
that
um I will say that there are situations
that come before the Attorney General's
Advisory board that specific cases or
specific complaints where we identify
weaknesses either in the protocol or in
members of the system following the
protocol as they should and when there
are weaknesses in the protocol we vote
as a board to amend the protocol to
ensure that it is calling for best
practices and when the protocol is
appropriate but it's not being
completely followed then we look for
ways through the Attorney General's
office through County Prosecutors
through the New Hampshire Chiefs of
Police Association to
um
to get the word down to the boots on the
ground for lack of a better word to
ensure that the process is being
followed and that's not specific only to
sexual assault investigations that's
every type of law enforcement
investigation you know we want to
improve and make sure that everybody's
using the best practices available
representative Palazzo
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my other question can you
help me understand when police got
involved so if a victim in eer
is a victim offered to
involve police or is there some
reporting requirements to report to
police's a and is it different like uh
on in different cases like one case if
there was like uh penetrated generally
even as a case when there was like
sexual assault without penetration or
suitcase like somebody was drugged let's
say for financial crime so in this
different scenarios like uh how police
got involved is it offered to victim or
is medical professional required to
report to police thank you thank you for
the question it is the uh survivor's
decision whether or not to involve the
police so a Survivor can go to a medical
professional for an anonymous kit and in
those situations the decision on whether
a kit is conducted and what pieces of
evidence are collected those decisions
are made by the medical provider because
the police are not involved and they
should be following the Attorney
General's protocol on that if the
Survivor chooses to involve the police
the police also should follow the
Attorney General's protocol but again
the more people that are involved in the
discussion in the investigation and
considering the facts of the case
um
the easier it is to come up with
additional investigative tools that
might be used to move a case forward
okay other questions
saying no other questions thank you
thank you for your time
hey I have no one else signed up to
testify on this bill does anyone else
wish to testify
seeing no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 378.
our next hearing is scheduled for 1pm uh
it's 11 56 currently so we're going to
be in recess until 1 pm until and in
that time we will be opening the public
hearing on HB 277. whatever news says
foreign
like to reconvene please
It's One o'clock And I would like to
open the public hearing on House Bill
and begin with recognizing the prime
sponsor representative Ellen Reed
and again representative Reed I believe
we need a card from you this time this
time you actually do need a card for me
I didn't fill it out in time last time I
had I always say it so
it's coming Mr chair again thank you Mr
chair and honorable members of the
committee
um again for the record my name is Ellen
Reed and I represent Newmarket in new
fields which is Rockingham 10 and I want
to apologize in advance this day is
most of my bills are in election law and
so this has been a very difficult day
and I didn't intend for both of the
bills that impacted me on a very very
personal level to be on the same day
before the same committee uh but thems
the breaks uh HB 277 is uh relative to a
patient's right to sterilization
treatment so once again I'm going to go
through a story and um that and this
happened to me
um I have never in my life had a regular
period
uh from the time that I started having
periods they were maybe four months but
it varied four months apart but then it
would be several weeks of heavy heavy
bleeding and my mom was not the kind of
person to like talk openly about these
things so it wasn't until I was in
college that I talked to a doctor and
the doctor kind of dismissed me and said
well as long as you're having a few a
year you're fine so
um it continued and it got worse to the
point that I went through a solid year
of bleeding every day bleeding every
single day for over a year
I finally got diagnosed in my late 20s
with PCOS
which is just as in a nutshell too many
hormones too many eggs
um goes and it's more than that but
that's basically what it is
so the they tried many different
treatments uh all of which have to do
with hormones and there was a
breakthrough bleeding through all of the
treatments I went through this for 12
years six different doctors
um did IUD NuvaRing implants pills all
of it it didn't fix the problem and and
it's worth noting that through all this
bleeding there's pain and um and
embarrassment and everything because
it's very heavy bleeding
I went through a particularly difficult
four months where the flow was so very
heavy for four months straight that
there was not a product on the market
that could control what I was going
through I had to wear adult diapers
um to to deal with what I was going
through
and that ended that four-month period
ended with apparently something that's
relatively rare called shedding a cast
which is essentially giving birth to a
mold of the inside of your uterus I have
never had children I don't want children
that never wanted children because I
raised my four younger brothers
um and so I didn't know what I was going
through I didn't know I was literally on
the phone with 9-1-1 when this was
happening and uh
so rewinding back through this entire
time I'm going through all these
different doctors they consistently tell
me well one of the treatment the ideal
treatment for you would be a
hysterectomy and I would say that's
great because my husband has already had
a vasectomy I chose at a young age to
not have children I haven't changed my
mind since we're not having children
and every single doctor told me no no
you're too young you don't know what
you're going to want in the future
you'll change your mind we're not going
to give you this treatment mind you Not
only would it have saved me all of the
pain and suffering and bleeding and
everything that I went through but also
as a PCOS sufferer I'm at an increased
risk for uterine cancer and ovarian
cancer 90 of ovarian cancer happens in
the Fallopian tubes which is removed
during a typical a typical hysterectomy
so I was put through increased risk of
cancer in addition to all of the
suffering that I went through for those
12 years until I was 38 and a doctor
finally decided that I was old and and
passed my child bearing years and
finally agreed to give me the
hysterectomy now through all of this
um I thought that this was just a me
thing the fact that I was getting told
no
um so I got the hysterectomy at 38 I
became state rep at 36 so two years I
suffered as a State Rep then three more
years before I put in this bill and the
only reason I put in this bill is
because I found a community of women
across the country actually that
experienced the same exact thing through
a number a number of different medical
conditions uh but we're being told no in
fact it's such a common practice in this
medical community to deny particularly
women although the bill is written in
gender-neutral language uh and sex
neutral but it's so such a common
practice that uh that the this community
of women across the country actually
curates a list of friendly doctors who
will in fact believe you when you say I
actually have made my mind up to not
have children
so um the bill I'll just walk through
there's three parts to the bill the
first part is that if a patient has a
medical diagnosis and a legitimate
treatment for that medical condition
includes a hysterectomy includes
sterilization treatment I should say
then the doctor cannot deny that
treatment if the patient so wants it on
the basis solely on the basis of the
doctor's perception of the patient's
future reproductive desires the doctor
can still deny it for religious reasons
the doctor can still deny it for payment
for any kind of medical reason any other
reason just not no no you don't know
what you want
the second part of the bill is that if
it's a voluntary procedure the doctor
can deny it
however the doctor has to refer them to
a a doctor who will perform the
procedure and takes their form of
payment
and the last part of the bill is simply
there to protect the doctors that the
doctor can require a signed informed
consent waiver saying that you know that
you're getting sterilized so you cannot
Sue and have no legal recourse when
you're sterile now you can still sue for
any number of
you know they left four steps in you or
what have you but but the point is is
that you knew you were becoming sterile
you made this decision and now you
cannot sue for being sterile and that's
the bill it's as simple as that but I
think I really want to bring it back to
the idea that these decisions need to be
in the hands of patients who are
full-grown people
and I just want to point out that the
hypocrisy of this medical community and
obviously there's not all because we
have this wonderful list of doctors that
are friendly and and believe patients
when they say this is the decision I've
made for myself
um but a lot of the culture of the
medical community they will say these
are the same people that say they
support a in particular a woman's right
to control her own body but then they
deny grown women with medical conditions
the right to make a choice for one of
those treatments for that condition
because no no I know better than you
what you're going to want in the future
these are also the same people who say
rightfully I think that they support
trans children rights to undergo
treatment and I understand trans
children almost never getting kind of
surgery but then sometimes hormonal
therapies uh can uh lead to
sterilization and I have very limited
knowledge about this I think that's
right but then they say that a
full-grown person doesn't get to say
whether or not they want this treatment
versus that treatment because no no we
know better than you
about what you're going to want in your
future
so I would really like to normalize the
idea that in particular because this
does impact women more that women get to
make up their minds as to whether or not
they have children and
um you know I know this is obviously not
an abortion Bill I know abortion is a
Hot Topic and I'm not looking to get
into that argument but this does reduce
the need for abortion because if people
have the right to to make that decision
ahead of time then you don't have to
deal with that problem
so I just want to normalize the idea of
living Child free lives and normalize
the idea that adults get to make their
decisions for their health care options
and I'm happy to take questions
any questions
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I've read the bill over several times
and I'm trying to understand it exactly
but my concern is or my question is
especially in part A is this mandating
that a physician or surgeon say a
gynecologist who is skilled at
hysterectomy
boarded
is forced to do a hysterectomy if he or
she does not want to do it or does not
think it's the appropriate course of
action no if they think it's an
inappropriate course of action for
medical reasons for religious reasons
they can still deny it the only thing it
says is that you can't deny it on the
basis of I think I know better than you
what you want to do with your future in
terms of children
that's the only condition
thank you um
so my question is if there is a
community of friendly Physicians or
surgeons or whomever will do the
procedure a serialization procedure why
does this become necessary then if there
are others that will do it as opposed to
somebody who does not feel it's the
appropriate medical procedure for you or
any patient so few and far between the
list that they had only contained four
doctors in all of New Hampshire
so
I think we have more people testifying
as to the need and for doctors would not
meet those needs
just one quick phone sure it does follow
up to the initial question so it does it
is a mandate of sorts then correct only
in the sense that a doctor can't insert
their personal opinion about your
personal decisions in the future
when it comes to making a decision
medically that's all it would be the
same as if a doctor were to insert their
opinion on who you should date or insert
their opinion on you know what color you
should wear the flavor of food that you
like they should not and I think it's
across the board they should not be
inserting those opinions those personal
opinions they should only be making
decisions based on your medical needs
and these are conditions where these
people mostly women mostly people with
uterus as I should say actually do need
these procedures which you will hear
more from
representative King thank you chairman
McDonald
thank you for taking questions
do you are you concerned at all with
unintended consequences blowback
um you know when you have somebody
potentially doing
um something that they really don't want
to for whatever reason they do it
begrudgingly that the quality of care
could be less than desirable and when
you're dealing with something like a
surgery that could could kill a person I
mean people do die in surgery do you do
you really want to have a doctor
performing a potentially deadly surgery
when he doesn't have
full Gusto the full weight of his
conscience supporting him do you really
want somebody that is only doing it
because the law says I mean I I
personally think that that could lead to
disasters
um
maybe it's better just to go the extra
distance find those four doctors that
can do it with their full conscience
behind them as opposed to somebody who's
just doing it because they have to I
mean that's that's scary to me so thank
you for the question we mandate a lot of
things out of the medical community
because anytime we have given a lot of
power to really anyone in society they
have a lot of responsibility back
doctors have a lot of power over people
because they control their health
so we mandate a lot of things so you
can't as a doctor for example
um insert any number of personal
opinions that would impact that
patient's Health you have to act in the
patient's best interest Hippocratic oath
and all of that so to the extent we're
normalizing the idea that that's how you
should actually be making decisions and
not through this kind of toxic basically
misogynistic culture that's a good thing
so
is it can you say that in the interim
while you're normalizing that that some
of these doctors might say you know what
my heart's really not in it why don't
you go to some other doctor yeah sure
that could happen but we have a standard
of care for a reason and and I really
think that if they're not willing to
listen to their patients desires about
what they want to do with their life
then maybe they should not be in that
particular field anyway and we should
not be normalizing that particular
mindset
other questions representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm concerned about
uh Patsy because we give some additional
immunity
and informative informed consent is
important but I'm concerned that
sometimes uh side effects are not
properly discussed like in my personal
experience
uh
just I mean before placidia I was made
to sign a paper like oh by the way all
this like and you may die and this side
effect and that side effect and it was
not discussed with me before but I
already like kind of concerned just
signing a paper
for me it's why do we need this
additional immunity
so I thank you for the question
um I agree with you I think the
committee knows now I agree with you
that doctors need to be informing their
patients a lot more than they currently
are in general
um and with some things in particular
so it that is a definite problem that
needs to be addressed it's a separate
problem than than this problem which is
specifically a misogynistic culture
making determinations mostly for women
um about what they can and can't
treatments they can and can't access so
yes the doctors need to be more
informative when it comes to things I it
I mean if you wanted to remove the
committee wanted to remove that that's
fine I was trying to help the medical
community out by saying okay we're
saying that you have to have this
standard of care so we're going to
protect you and kind of balance that out
it's up to the committee if you want to
leave that in
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
thank you so much
I'm sorry representative Missouri yeah
representative I'm sorry no no it's fine
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so you mentioned that list of
four providers currently who would do
this so how do you foresee that that
list would grow with the passage of this
like because it sounds like
maybe they've already made that decision
and that's why they put themselves on
that list of four providers well they
don't put themselves on but yeah
but so you think that others
would willingly be added to that list I
think that once you're saying you cannot
behave in this way anymore that you're
normalizing a better healthier culture
and attitude towards patients rights to
make their own decisions when it comes
to their treatment when it's legitimate
medical decisions now I'm not ever
saying that they should be able to make
a decision that is not in their medical
best interest but these are doctors is
saying yeah this is medically best for
you but
you're going to want to have kids so by
normalizing that that is by saying that
that's not good and normalizing a
culture that
rightfully gives the decision to the
patients you're going to end up with
more and more doctors that see this as
the correct way of doing things
because it's the legal way of doing
things yeah and you also mentioned the
misogynistic culture
um is that in the provider field or like
cultural in culture in general because
there are I know of many many many
female providers so being female does
not disqualify you from being
misogynistic
um that those two things are independent
of each other and we unfortunately have
a culture going back into history that
sees women as reproducers
sees the role of women primarily early
in life as having to look a certain way
and then later in life as producing
children and that's the main role of
women that's an old very old-fashioned
way of looking at it but it's still the
the remnants of it are still in our
culture today and to the the extent that
it's still in our culture today the
medical field has adopted some of that
because they are denying people the
right to have needed needed procedures
medically necessary procedures because
no no you're going to want to have kids
even when I tell you as a 32 year old I
don't
other questions
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
representative Daniel
papavichi Mueller
hopefully I
announce that fairly close
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members and by the way up to
now it was the absolute best first shot
at my last name or second shot at my
last name that I've had again keep it to
three minutes that'd be great
excuse me I was planning to speak very
briefly and I will try to keep it very
brief
when I learned about this bill
I read it and
I really you know it seems like a very
straightforward type of situation where
we should respect people's rights to
make
decisions that only affect themselves
right it's my body I should have the
ability to control what I do to it
you know there are plenty of things that
I see other people do that I disagree
with but it's their body you know I'm
not there to tell them what the
consequences of that may be
so to me I look at it from the point of
view of just respecting people's agency
and I want to make it very clear that I
do not feel in any way that anybody is
trying to treat people differently
because of you know
being women or men or whatnot but there
is a implicit assumption in a lot of us
that actually is seen in a lot of other
legal areas where there are biases in
the law in the practice that were put
there forward seemed like good reasons
at the time
and which are no longer good reasons
if you look at this bill there were
questions rate about a couple of things
one of them would be in letter A that a
physician may be less than a hundred
percent when required to perform a
procedure they really disagree with
and I've spoken with you know medical
doctors and I I agree that that is a you
know concern
but I want to point out that while the
text of the law does not specifically
say you can deny it by referring it to
somebody else it does not prevent that
choice from being offered to the patient
the doctor who will tell the patient
look if I have to do this procedure I
will do it but I think he would be best
off if you went to this doctor that also
takes this insurance who would feel much
more comfortable and has done this more
often and you would be in better hands
most patients would probably be very
happy to be recommended that way in the
rare situations when that's not a choice
it seems that the only choice the
patient has is to not receive a
treatment that's medically necessary and
there are balances we have to make the
Mandate part concerned me right I
thought about it because it is
Meaningful but I think it's a minimal
infringement a minimal mandate in very
specific circumstances and for good
reasons
we're just talking about on the basis of
perceived future reproductive desires of
the patient there are many other reasons
why this procedure can be denied
medically and so on but that's just not
a good reason as far as I'm concerned
the other question was for
representative polosov in terms of the
waiver of liability the waiver of
liability is essential in this bill
because you are mandating that medical
providers do this legally how would it
be fair for them to then be sued in
civil court for doing what the patient
told them and they had a legal
obligation to do I mean if we are going
to have a mandate we have to have the
shield from civil liability for that
mandate we create
this is no different than you know 28
day if we impose a spending mandate we
should pay for it if you impose this
mandate then you should provide the
proper shield for the Physicians
and um you can start wrapping up please
I will and I really appreciate it
actually I'm gonna wrap it right right
now I know that I took more than one
minute but I did expand a little bit
from my original plans and I appreciate
your understanding thank you sir
uh questions yes representative McLean
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um in uh paragraph B of the bill which
is basically when you're asking for a
sterilizing procedure without any
underlying medical condition
the bill allows you to say no I'm not
comfortable with that but I'm going to
refer you to another position
but in in section A that right of
referral is denied to the position so it
is effectively in in part A a mandate
that says they do have to do it because
the option of referral is taken away do
you know why
um why that right of referral was
included in section B but not in section
A
I cannot speak for the prime sponsor and
it's not a question I ask them directly
but I will say that as somebody who had
a discussion about an optional
sterilization procedure somewhere in my
40s with my physician my experience has
been that I got no pushback whatsoever
and yet I read about a lot of story
about people who have that pushback a
lot in exactly the situation prescribed
in paragraph B so
personally and I hope I'm not getting in
trouble here I wouldn't really
object to the committee
expanding that language to paragraph a
as long as a physician can be found that
will perform that procedure if this is
what the committee feels is the best way
to go forward at the end of the day this
is your bill now and I believe that any
form of language that respects the
intent is language that I would support
but the intent of this is to make sure
that the people's right to make a
decision about their own body that only
affects them
is respected you know based on that
criteria so I would really not you know
object to that potential expansion of
the language to you know refer in a
thank you thank you other questions
see no other questions thank you very
much
also signed up to speak is Virginia
Sykes
yeah a few minutes ma'am
good morning Mr chair and honorable
members of the committee thank you for
hearing this bill today
um I'm going to be speaking mostly about
part c
um I grew up in a family of doctors my
grandfather was a physician as was his
father before him
and my uncle is also a doctor
I grew up in the medical community and
hearing a lot about complaints about
medical malpractice and this that and
the other thing
I've known since I was 16 I did not want
children I I strongly believe from the
bottom of my heart if you can't look at
children and say oh my God I want that
child more than anything they make me
happy they bring me joy you shouldn't
have children and I could only even as a
preschool teacher and many many other
children
I could never look at a child and say
having this in my life would bring me
joy would make me want them as anything
other than a duty and so since I was 16
I've told my gynecologist I want to get
sterilized now I say oh no no you're too
young you're too young
and I'm now 33 and I still want to be
sterilized
um
because quite frankly the most
horrifying thing I can think of is
getting pregnant
it is to me
I would rather die than have a child for
personal reasons
I don't want them not only do they not
want them I don't think the quality of
life of a child I could bring to this
world would be worth having for them
because I'm on a lot of medications
and I'd have to get off of it which
would leave me in excruciating pain for
the months it would take to have this
child plus breastfeeding
I don't see the balance
but
one thing that's important here is I was
told later in my life that to get enough
to get a sterilization I would have to
go through two psychiatric appointments
and then three meetings with the
gynecologist
and I said okay why
and the doctor said because I don't want
to get sued
so I think the most important part of
this bill is in fact the legal
protection of doctors for sterilization
procedures because then that list of
four people those four people say okay
yeah no I know what women want what they
want they're probably not going to
change their mind those people that
think oh well you know women they're
very fickle and they change their mind
they're going to have this legal
protection now that they say okay look
you can't sue me for sterilizing you
they now maybe will get on that list I
think the most important part is that
legal protection that will encourage
doctors to take a procedure they might
not have earlier taken because of the
legal protections and I can answer any
questions to that particular part
okay thank you questions
seeing no questions okay thank you
thank you for having me
also signed up to speak is Jason velardi
everyone
hi everybody how are you
okay uh so I just want to talk briefly
on uh sort of the situation in which I
find myself here I am in support of this
um but I want to talk a bit about how
the uh experience between a male uh
getting sterilization uh myself and my
wife was a bit different uh and and
we're still kind of working through that
but essentially
um after our second child was born and
we had made attempts prior to talk about
uh his directory for my wife and also
vasectomy for myself
um the the option for me to walk into
the office two months after my second
was born and get a vasectomy was simple
five minutes doctor said you understand
what you were doing I said yes sent me
on my way I set up a scheduled
appointment came and got it done she has
been trying now to get someone to even
think about doing a hysterectomy for her
um for gosh as long as I've known her
for about 15 years here
the issue is more that getting the right
people to
talk with her and speak with her and
understand where she's coming from and
then understanding all of the maladies
that kind of live with her she's
essentially giving this issue to herself
where she spends about a week every
month in bed in extreme pain a lot of it
stemming from her period in her
menstrual cycle
and the remedy is to remove her uterus
but the issue is you need to have
children you're not old enough you got
to wait have some children we had two
children now it's well you don't know
you have to take medicine for the rest
of your life she understands that we
both are in the medical field we come
from medical backgrounds the key piece
here is that we need to ensure that the
Physicians are informing their patients
and that they can then consent to the
procedure
you mentioned signing the piece of paper
right before you got your procedure if
you could find me a physician who can
give you a piece of paper and do a
procedure same day please let me know
who it is because uh that is few and far
between nowadays usually we're booking
six months out out so a patient would
have to understand exactly what they're
signing up to do prior to any sort of
scheduling because obviously cash is
King and unless they can pay for it and
understand what they're paying for they
wouldn't even be considered to have this
procedure done so again it's very
important that we allow people to get
these decisions or get into the hands of
the right people who can help them when
they are unavailable to them
and that's all I had to say thank you
any questions
say no questions okay thank you thanks
also signed up to speak is Jennifer
Bosco Webb
three minutes ma'am
I timed it I'm right on the dot there
you go okay
hi I'm Jen uh and I'm in support of this
bill
um
for the simple fact that the idea that
we live in a society where the medical
field pushes biological Parenthood above
everything else such as pain and quality
of life is incredibly troubling
especially when they're a medically
proven benefits of individuals having
the right to make their own biological
decisions around their medical decisions
personally I'm surprised I haven't
ruined my liver with the amount of
Tylenol and Midol I consume every month
in an attempt to make the crippling pain
manageable which I'm sure several people
can relate with
it isn't just the unpredictable and
inconvenient bleeding that wreaks havoc
on our quality of life it's a sudden
Rush of hormones that change the anatomy
of our bodies and deplete our bodies of
energy it's the debilitating and literal
blinding migraines the bone deep back
pain the nausea and vomiting among many
other menstrual cycle symptoms
when I was in my early 20s I was
diagnosed with endometriosis which is a
disease that causes the uterine lining
to grow outside of the uterus the pain
from this disease is Indescribable
constant and especially bad during my
cycle
um
when I tell you that my pain tolerance
is high I'm not joking I've woken up in
the middle of two surgeries and opted to
stay awake to watch the procedure I
don't know why
um so when I tell you that the sudden
sharp pain that hits without warning can
drop me to my knees in less than a
second you can rest assured that the
pain is not exaggerated
it's hard to reach your potential in
being a functioning member of society
when many of us only experience two
weeks a month that are not consumed by
the debilitating symptoms that accompany
a menstrual cycle
especially when they're as severe as
many women experience
the easiest solution for many is a
hysterectomy
for many birth control is not an option
many times the risks outweigh the
benefits but when women seek to have a
procedure such as a hysterectomy we are
told no and asked but what if you want
children someday which is a question I'm
sure is weighed heavily on the
individual who is seeking sterilization
when the chronic pain prevents us from
living children are often the last
priority on our minds or we're so
desperate to better our quality of life
we're willing to push our dreams of
giving birth aside just for any sense of
relief
how fair would it be to our children if
we were only able to be present half of
the time if we're lucky furthermore
motherhood does not stop at carrying and
birthing your child women who wish to
have children are no less of a mother if
they adopt
when doctors try convincing us that the
most important thing is prioritizing the
preservation of fertility we are being
gaslit and denied basic human rights
it's a response that is rooted in a long
history of the medical establishment
trivializing and dismissing pain
reported by women it also reflects the
stereotypical views about the proper
function of women in our bodies that our
most important function is to have
children and if we don't we are failing
somewhere
when I reached my breaking point I asked
my doctor about a hysterectomy and I was
told no I had a decision made for me
without my consent a decision that could
have made the last 22 years of my life a
lot more pain-free and enjoyable and a
decision that would protect me from the
ovarian and cervical cancer that runs
rampant through my family
I still don't have children and I would
be okay with not carrying a child
adoption has always been a welcome
option for my husband and I in a route I
would happily travel if I were able to
make the decision to have a hysterectomy
myself
we're a state in which we proudly
showcase our model of Live Free or Die
yet every citizens in New Hampshire
especially women are not given the right
to live freely and make our own medical
decisions
and that is all I have
thank you
any questions
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question would
would you be comfortable I'll ask you
the same question I asked a co-sponsor
would you be comfortable if the
legislation was amended so that if you
were to go to the doctor and they're
really not comfortable giving that
procedure that okay I can't
uh do that for you but I can refer you
to somebody who will so if we move that
language into the top part of the bill
would you be comfortable with that
Amendment
um I personally would be I think as
mentioned before there aren't many
options out there so as long as the
if as long as the
um
the doctor the surgeon was
willing to do the the procedure yes I
would be more comfortable with that
being there thank you
other questions
okay no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Elaine
Swanson
you have three minutes good afternoon
everyone thank you for having me today
I'm here today to talk in support and
about something very personal and a
story that I don't often share with
people especially a room full of
strangers
and that story is my health history and
the decisions that I have made for my
body and my future because of that
history
when I was two years old my family and I
discovered that I had a blood disorder
called spherocytosis it's where my red
blood cells are spherical instead of
donut shaped and my condition is a
hereditary disorder and at the age of
two I was it was causing severe anemia
and fatigue
and over the years as my body grew up I
started to experience some severe issues
at eight years old I developed
gallstones and an enlarged spleen and
unfortunately a lot of memories of my
abdominal area in so much pain that I
would actually pass out from it
so when I was nine I had my spleen and
my gallbladder removed now when they
were doing that surgery the surgeons
discovered that because I had strained
and clenched my abdominal region so much
that I actually caused bilateral hernias
they didn't repair this right away in
that surgery so after a couple of years
of healing and my body adjusting to the
first surgery I then had this hernia
repair in my teens
I had a few years of Peace in terms of
my health issues until I hit my early
20s when I was diagnosed with stage two
Hodgkin's lymphoma a blood cancer that
for my age range at the time was a high
survivorship rate
before I began my abvd chemo and
radiation treatments I was given the
option to freeze my eggs
and this was the first time at 22 years
old I really had to start thinking about
my desire to have kids
we talked about the process of egg
extraction and at that time with
everything that I was going through
anything else happening to me was just
too much so I went with my intuition and
I said no to having my ex Frozen
and went through chemo and radiation
and that decision really stuck with me
but in a very positive way
because as the years continued I kept
thinking and learning about how I would
feel if I were to physically have a
child of my own
the idea of growing a baby inside of my
womb and giving birth is not a beautiful
aspiration to everybody
for some people it can be a very
terrifying experience
and so ever since then I led with my
intuition and I said
I led with my intuition when I said no
to having my eggs frozen and I have been
researching talking to doctors friends
family and myself
and genuinely considering sterilization
and after seven years of this when I was
29 I began the process
what I was expecting to hear was much
like what you have heard and will hear
today denial dismissal but I wasn't met
with any of that
my doctor listened to my whole story
told me the risks told me it was
irreversible
and we decided together that an elective
bilateral salpinectomy a tube removal
was the best course of action for me
and in 2021 I hopefully had the last
surgery on my abdomen and I removed my
fallopian tubes
I like to say that I'm grateful for
compassionate and understanding doctors
who helped me get that surgery but it's
not just them
I'm grateful for doctors who put the
well-being of their Patient First which
is their job
you could be wrapping up please okay
because the only reason a two-year-old
little girl was able to survive to the
31 year old I am today is because of
doctors who cared about their patient my
life and my well-being
and to dismiss or to dismiss or deny
anyone an elective surgery that could
help them in their mental condition
based on a preconceived future
reproductive desires that a doctor
places on a patient is inappropriate and
wrong
so that's why I'm here today to advocate
for doctors to advocate for patients and
thank you for your time thank you any
questions questions
say no questions thank you very much
also signed up to speak is Lauren Fitch
flower and Fitch here
good afternoon
you put seven minutes I'd really need
you to keep it around three please
my name is Lauren Fitch I Am a Child
free lifestyle Advocate speaker
podcaster and most importantly a woman
I'm originally from Maryland but I have
a network of child-free women all over
the world who are telling me their
stories every day I moderate a Facebook
group of over 10 000 of these women
I'd like to begin my testimony by
telling you a funny story that my mother
always likes to tell
when I was three years old I looked up
at her at the grocery store and I said
Mom I'm not having kids and she said
well that's a funny thing to say what
are you gonna do so I said I'm gonna be
a working girl I'm gonna work at
McDonald's
luckily
I shot higher in my career path but one
thing hasn't changed since I was three
years old I have never wanted children
when I was 14 years old I was diagnosed
with endometriosis I was bleeding so
much that I was passing out
I started asking my gynecologist what
could surgically be done at 15 put on
birth control at the age of 12. 12.
because my periods were so heavy that I
was passing out in school
despite me begging him to sterilize me
and give me the ablation every year
until I turned 24 he retired without
doing the procedure
when I moved to New England I went to
another doctor
she said let's try the depo-provera shot
I went into anaphylactic shock from
birth control
that is not an option for me anymore
after telling my new gynecologist
about those issues she once again
suggested maybe you should try a
hormonal IUD
I have found a doctor off of that list
that Ellen mentioned earlier who will
sterilize me except she doesn't accept
my insurance
so it's live with it or Fork up ten
thousand dollars that me and my fiance
do not have
I would also like to talk to you about
how important the freedom to choose a
child-free life is
I know in my heart
that motherhood is not for me
and I'm frustrated that I am supposed to
live my life sick with not only
endometriosis but with a lupus diagnosis
because someone thinks I don't know
myself
if I was 27 and seeking IVF treatment I
would be encouraged
if I was 27 and wanted to have a baby
everyone would say congratulations
but if I'm 27
and want serious treatment to prevent
something that could very well kill me
because I also have lupus
I'm denied
Child free people think about the
decision to have kids daily
my partner and I touch on this topic at
least once a week
we weigh the pros and cons we think
about the future
probably than people who simply have
baby fever do
we are teachers therapists scientists
writers reporters doctors nurses and
good citizens who by the way are the
only group of adults in the US who are
actually taxed into poverty
and who do not have access to social
welfare programs
we are discriminated against by
employers we are not given the same
legal protections as parents in this
country so all we are asking you to do
today is the ability to choose for
ourselves what we want to do
I had a
miscarriage I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant
in September of 2021 because I have
Lupus I
started to go into kidney failure I went
septic and had to have an emergency DNE
as well as emergency surgery on my
kidneys and now I will never be off of
medication
I do not want that to happen again
let's start wrapping up please ma'am
Parenthood is beautiful but only if you
want it and the only person who knows if
you want it is you
my mother loved being a mother
but it's not for me
I will stay Child free no matter how
this hearing goes today no matter what
you decide to do
but you have the power to decide if I
have to live sick
or if I can have the freedom to live how
I want
I can take questions are there any
questions for this lady
you don't see any okay thank you very
much
also signed up signed up to speak is
Jade flad velardi
hi again hi again three minutes you know
the drill my three minutes let's get
this in all right
um hello
you're related to that gentleman on the
front row there that is my husband
I noticed the similarity of last name
yes yes well you know
super feminist because I you know
put our names together
but anyway okay so getting into this
um my name is Jade you guys know me I am
from New Hampshire born and raised here
um after I met my husband in college
he's from Long Island after college we
decided New Hampshire is the best place
that we want to be to raise our children
um like a lot of other speakers I came
up here today who said that they have
known that they don't want children from
very young age I have known that I've
wanted children from a very young age
also
um it's always been uh something that I
saw myself doing in the future when I
was ready
um after college my husband and I moved
back here we lived in Portsmouth for a
number of years we got married and when
I went to my physical exam to tell my
doctor I'm ready to start trying having
children
she asked me okay you need to prepare to
go off birth control in order for
ovulation to start back up and I told
her I hadn't been on any sort of birth
control for at least five six years now
and she looks me dead in the eye and she
goes you've never had a miscarriage I'm
like not that I know of and she goes so
you've never accidentally got gotten
pregnant in these eight years that you
are not using birth control and I said
no and she said to me you better start
trying now because you probably have
fertility issues and I'm like huh weird
I thought I just knew how creating
children worked and then avoided making
a child that way so
my so I come home I tell my husband you
know this lady saying that I might have
fertility issues and you have to be
trying for a year in order to get any
sort of assistance with fertility
um
for me
it was just crazy that she she this this
provider this woman who who knows
exactly how women's bodies work is
highly educated has known me for years
knows my background was acting like I
didn't know what I was talking about
that I was not educated enough to make
real actual decisions for my body and
couldn't believe that I could use
a system for Family Planning that didn't
involve chemicals hormones or surgeries
like
that that right there is why I think
that this bill is really important
because it's the medical gaslighting
that needs to stop I know gaslighting is
kind of like a hot trendy word but it's
it really is what it is
um patients come in complaining of of uh
symptoms or you know awful periods or
not wanting to have children for
legitimate reasons genetic defects abuse
they have experienced and just I don't
know maybe not wanting to bring children
into this whatever this country is left
because what are they going to have
other than chemical spills and more
doctor bills but um for me I think it's
really important we pass this bill
to preserve the autonomy of the patients
and to give patients even the leg up to
be taken seriously by Healthcare
professionals from some of the questions
I'm hearing from you guys today it's
very obvious that
um we regard doctors as the smartest the
most intelligent they know what they're
talking about they went through all the
schooling okay that's great you could
start wrapping up please however these
doctors are just like the rest of us
they are overworked they're seeing too
many patients and there's no way they
can actually know and give time and
research your your specific conditions
in order to
make that justify them right
um
I want to talk about something called
pmdd which remember if you could start
wrapping up please okay
for me I need a hysterectomy because I
have something called pmdd pmdd is like
PMS except on the extreme end two weeks
before my period every month I become
deeply depressed I become
suicidal I become the a complete monster
I have two children I've already had my
children I was done having children by
the time I was 30. I suffer all of these
things every single month and to this
day no matter what I say no matter how
much I say I went to mass College of
Pharmacy I have a degree in medical you
know stuff I worked at hospitals my
husband works at hospitals I have
friends who are telling me that this is
accurate information and I'm still being
denied because some doctor thinks that
I'm too young to go on hormone therapy
or I'm too young to be sterilized or you
know there are other options I've
exhausted every option I've tried all
the birth control I have done everything
and even with legitimate reason to get a
hysterectomy done I'm still met with no
this is not you this is not this is this
is not right for you when I know it
understand I've got to ask you to stop
please okay does anybody have any
questions about that
does anyone have any questions for this
lady
uh no yeah okay thank you thank you so
much for listening I really hope that
you know you make this real
I have no one else signed up to speak on
House Bill 277
pink slim can I just have two minutes
please uh yeah you need to do a pink
card though please sir
yep yep
please bring it forward
thank you
uh Stephen and Steven scare Nashua New
Hampshire
so thank you very much chairman for
accommodating me I will be the three
minutes please what's that you have
three minutes
I can do it in two okay I'm concerned
that this is this law is going to apply
to boys and girls who are being confused
about their gender told their in the
wrong bodies and given puberty blockers
and opposite sex hormones that will
leave them sexually dysfunction and
sterile
although children might legally be able
to offer informed consent for these
treatments there's no way a teen much
less a 10 year old can understand the
consequences of these treatments we have
tens of thousands of detransitioners
describing lives of pain and regret this
law would only facilitate procedures
that cause permanent damage to boys and
girls many of whom have autism or other
mental health disorders
in other words it would establish a
religious belief that were born with
gendered souls or gender identities and
these not our bodies are our authentic
selves and so our bodies may need to be
modified for a different perspective I'd
encourage you to hear the
detransitioners who are suffering to
tell their stories and gen specs d-trans
Awareness Day a live webinar at 6 PM
March 12th so thank you any questions
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you sir
and could we get a copy of that
testimony sir
yes sir
representative Heinz
okay
foreign
thank you Dan hi thank you Mr chair Dan
Hines represent the the town of Bedford
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill I support
uh this bill uh specifically is not for
children um paragraph B says dealing
with people 18 or age of higher um part
a
um deals with medically advisable stuff
so if there is a medical condition that
someone needs it
um this bill is a medical Freedom bill I
would ask you to support it and I won't
be taking questions in the interest of
time thank you okay thank you
okay uh no applause please no applause
um anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill 277.
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 277. and I
think it's two o'clock uh
up now we have four minutes at which
time we will begin we will open the
public hearing on cacr8 so we have a
we'll be adjourn we'll recess for five
minutes
thank you
like I understand all right
good afternoon it's a 202 by my watch
anyway
I'd like to reconvene and open the
public hearing on cacr8 and accordingly
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Dan Hines
good afternoon representative Hans
Redland thank you I'll start over thank
you Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Dan Hines representing town of
Bedford and I think we all agree that we
have a fundamental and human right to
have children or not I think we take for
granted that part of that is the right
to access birth control however that is
not an explicit constitutional right
it's not found in the Federal
Constitution it's not found in the state
constitution this bill would explicitly
put in our state constitution the right
to access birth control some might say
why is this needed we already have the
right to birth control I would say
presently we do
um but who knows in the future different
constitutional rights come and go at the
whim of certain Supreme Court Justices
so this is essentially a preventative
measure so that a right that I think
everyone just takes for granted will be
classified in our Constitution and
cannot be removed from us I saw various
polls recently and over the years ninety
percent of the people consistently agree
there's the right to access birth
control so this would put it to it's
because of the Constitutional Amendment
put it to voters and I think it would
overwhelmingly pass
this bill is not an abortion bill it's
medical Freedom Bill the reason it's not
an abortion bill is because it um I put
findings of fact and it does say it's
the right to access birth control to
prevent pregnancy
um it's not the access to free birth
control just the access to obtain birth
control
um
I think it's a just a common sense bill
that we all outright that we
expressly or inherently I think have
whether it's in the Constitution or not
but I think it needs to be in the
Constitution it's codify that right make
it clear that this is a right that's
important worth protecting and that
should be explicit in the Constitution
so that it cannot be infringed in the
future and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you my questions from the
committee
wow
you see no questions representative all
right
thank you thank you
thank you um I have no one else signed
up to testify on this um Bill and
representative Reed did you want to
testify on cacr8 or
I don't I'm not trying to put you on the
spot if you didn't want to I wasn't sure
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members for the record my name
is Ellen Reed and I represent Newmarket
in new Fields Rockingham 10 and I'm in
support of this bill because I think
you've already witnessed today I'm in
support of patient rights and the
ability of people to make their own
decisions in their own life I kind of
think that's the American way so
is that our pink card you're holding it
is Mr chair thank you
thank you
any questions for either of these uh
they're both the responses the sponsor
and co-sponsor of the cacr uh as
representative who do you want to ask a
question of
representative Reed or okay I would like
to get the bill
uh my my question about
uh uh about your expectation if this
bill uh in future will create some
mandates to fund birth control
no I think it all it means is that you
can't be denied
we have lots of Rights
so we have we have a lot of Rights but
not all of them are guaranteed
monetarily
representative freshman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so I understand we do have lots of
Rights
enumerated in the Constitutions but
um
most if not all of those don't require
the labor of other people
and when you require the labor of other
people
um whether they want to do it or not
it's slavery and I'm just thinking if
there were birth control supply chain
shortages and everyone goes to CVS
demanding their you know
um they're guaranteed right to birth
control you know I I just see a lot of
unintended consequences for this bill
um well for you know especially being in
the Constitution
and I'm just wondering what you know
eventually if people in prison will say
we have a right to contraceptives the
state has to pay for it
um you could see uh you know any other
branch of government where
you know we have a responsibility to the
people that we're serving that they
could say this is the right that you
need to provide for me
thank you very much for the question
um I think the best analog for us to
think about with respect to this is the
federal Second Amendment you have a
right to bear arms you have a right to
your Firearms doesn't mean the
government's going to pay for the
Firearms doesn't mean that you know if
there's a shortage that you're being
denied your rights but no one the
government can't step in and say you
don't have a right and we can talk about
other providers infringing on that right
so it gets into some interesting as we
all know there have been many court
cases about what private entities can
and can't do when it comes to the Second
Amendment so if you believe in the
Second Amendment then I think you have a
good framework to understand the right
to contracept
Ive
thank you so perhaps
an amendment
that changed it to not bear birth
control but
um self-administer birth control or
shall not be denied utilize birth
control or contraceptives if I may and
this will be up to the chair um bring
the prime sponsor up to maybe I think he
might be better able to speak to what
language might be uh getting to the
point of the bill that might make
everybody happy representative Divine
said you want to come up
oh
thank you so the reason I put access
birth control is I think that made it
clear that it wasn't free
um and I follow up with what
representative Reed said I would equate
to the Second Amendment um that yes if
we can't access it that's not the
provide this isn't depriving anyone's
labor this is saying the federal
government cannot ban birth control so
if there's different language that's
used out of support I just thought
access was the best to make it clear
that it's just not
essentially free and one of the things
but also once we do have a
constitutional um right as you know
that's not the end-all um States or you
know States legislatures pass laws that
touch on those things and the courts
apply the appropriate scrutiny so
I use the word access because I thought
that's most clear but if there's
separate language that I guess everyone
is on board with i would support that
should not be denied
yeah I think it just comes down to
possessing without shall not infringe
stay coming and saying no
representative Murphy
um thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question I'm just I just want
to make clear we don't have a mandate
against access to birth control right
now do we no
um and but I think all our rights follow
Supreme Court decisions
um so there are a couple which is good
but
um no there's nothing
I guess state law no there's nothing
prohibiting it but I think it is
something important that should be
codified so going forward a certain
different legislature might say yeah we
don't like that right anymore I will add
to that answer that and I just testified
to this on the Free Speech in in
College's uh bill that I don't believe
in waiting until oppression happens to
prevent it from happening we have a
second amendment in the New Hampshire
Constitution even though we have it on
the guaranteed on the federal level we
still have belts and suspenders
protected that right on the state level
as well so
um yeah just a quick follow-up so are we
aware of anything either in the state or
in the country of people being denied
birth control pills
are you aware of that
I am aware of birth control I should say
I'm aware of a political movement that
seeks to deny access to birth control
has anybody been denied access to birth
control that we are aware of in the
country even
I mean one could say the the employees
that what was it Hobby Lobby
things things of that sort on the
private level so yeah there are entities
and organizations that seek to deny that
and if they are able to control state
legislatures or town governments then I
think that they would take that action I
guess I would just add it's presently a
right that's the Supreme Court has given
us so no States can't go beyond that but
again that right because it's not
explicitly in the Federal Constitution
is it the whim of five justices
other questions
so you know other questions okay thank
you both thank you
I would ask if anyone else wants to
testify but no one else is here
so I'm going to close the public hearing
on cacr8
we have no other bills noticed with
today so we are adjourned uh until next
Tuesday morning